create a new chapter detailing a
consumer expectation of privacy
as you all know we have a constitutional
amendment concerning privacy so it is
something that is vitally important to
the people in the state of New Hampshire
and today people produce 25 times the
online data they did in 2010 recording
just about every single aspect of their
everyday life
but New Hampshire citizens today have no
rights to control their personal data
and businesses have no obligations to
Steward the data they hold
or respect the wishes of consumers when
they ask that their personal information
not be distributed or what they want
deleted
Senate Bill 255 will establish the
rights of consumers to protect their
data and the responsibility of
businesses they deal with to respect
their customers privacy wishes
this bill grants all of us the consumer
the right to access correct delete and
obtain a copy of personal data and gives
us rights to opt out of the processing
of our personal data for certain
purposes
it also establishes a framework for
controlling and processing personal data
and establishes responsibilities and
private privacy protection standards for
the various businesses that control and
or process our personal data
Senate Bill 255 is modeled after
legislation that has passed in Virginia
Colorado and Connecticut and in this
legislative session this model has
passed one body in Texas and Montana and
is very close to being enacted in
Indiana having passed both bodies
this model has been evaluated and worked
on by many of the same stakeholders and
industries that do business here in New
Hampshire
this bill is comprehensive it covers a
lot of material which is the result of
years of work and discussions all of
which is necessary to provide rights for
consumers while minimizing disruption to
Commerce
it has a thorough definition section
clearly establishes consumer rights
creates obligations on the part of
controllers
who are those who have the relationship
with the consumer and obligations for
processors are those who process data on
behalf of the controllers
it is time that the state of New
Hampshire acts to provide rights to
Consumers to control their personal data
held by businesses and this legislation
is a meaningful first step in
establishing those rights Mr chairman at
this point I think I've kind of given an
overview of the bill
um as and as you know it is
there's a lot of material in here and
there are experts here that have worked
on this legislation that would be able
to answer very detailed technical
questions that I don't have the ability
to answer so I would just say thank you
very much and I appreciate your time and
your consideration on this Bill thank
you Mr chairman great thank you did
anybody have any questions for the
senator given what she said yes um Mr
chair I don't necessarily have questions
for the senator but I have questions for
the people following the senator if if
that's true no no that's exactly I think
we all probably have questions thank you
very much I'm sure you do Mr chairman
thank you thank you all very much again
for your time and I appreciate it oh you
do want to ask a question I was just
going to ask general questions that
maybe people following could answer but
I could wait until they get up if that's
okay whatever works oh no I I didn't
want to stop you from asking questions
if you did but all right all right I
think we're all set thank you thank you
again Mr chairman all right
um I know Senator Susie um I don't think
she's here now she indicated she had a
conflict if um if we see her come in I
may take her out of order but um uh next
I'm going to represent uh recognize
representative Luna co-sponsor of the
bill
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee
um my name is Dave luno and I represent
the people of Merrimack County District
9 who live in Hopkinton bow and and
Concord and uh I serve on the education
committee so right next door and and you
folks are welcome to drop in anytime
we're always over there so um so they're
only letting us letting me out briefly
uh this morning
um but um but I agree with uh with with
everything that Senator Carson just um
uh just laid out as far as the the
rationale behind uh introduction of this
legislation there is no protection of um
of of
personally identifiable information uh
in codified in New Hampshire statute so
this is a meaningful first step I think
as she described it to um uh to bring us
there but a little bit of history and um
and uh representative Kirk I think we'll
we'll also be talking a little bit about
some of the history here we we have
different positions when it comes to to
this bill but um but um but Neil and I
have uh have spent a considerable amount
of time together working on these issues
and similar issues and back in 2019 uh
we were we were both members of a study
committee uh following an earlier Bill
along with representative hunt and
Senator Kavanaugh and um and as a result
of that study committee we um uh we
introduced House Bill 536 uh which is
really directed to um to protecting
privacy of biometric you know data that
that is collected and um and 536 is very
very different than this bill it um uh
it was uh first of all it was only maybe
a half a page long as opposed to I don't
know what we're here like 20 Pages or
something I don't have it right in front
of me at the moment but but 536
provided a
basically modified the consumer
protection act 350 a day to give
consumers a private right of action
should they feel that they're um that
their privacy rights had been violated
by a um uh by by a company they were
doing business with and um and that bill
actually passed it was recommended out
to pass 20 nothing out of the Commerce
Committee and they hardly ever do that
and um uh and passed on a Voice vote on
the on the floor of the house it was
later retained in the Senate but uh but
I liked it quite a bit because
um because it did provide for that
private right of action under 358a it
also allowed the Department of Justice
to uh to proceed to protect a consumer's
right when it came to violations of
their their personally identifiable
information so SB 255 doesn't go that
far it limits the the action to the
Department of Justice
but but more importantly I think it's
very specific and it's very
comprehensive in terms of what
personally identifiable information is
what the biometric data is and and what
constitutes a violation of of someone's
privacy rights and what um and it also
sets some standards for uh for companies
for businesses to comply with those
privacy rights and why is that important
um so again going back to the work that
we did in 2019 our committee researcher
Pam smarling actually
provided us with several reports
based on what companies and at the time
were doing as far as privacy notices so
so this goes to page nine line 16-26 of
the uh of the bill
with respect to privacy notices and why
is this important because companies like
ancestry and 23andMe had privacy notices
that were 15 pages long in one case 18
pages long in another case and buried
um you know in some cases you know
starting on page 40 of a um of a of a of
an agreement with the customer and I
think you know most of us have have um
have either purchased some technology
whether that's a uh you know uh you know
piece of internet technology or or um or
or a camera or even a car nowadays where
where you have to agree with privacy
notices before you can um you know can
proceed so having some Stan and does
everybody read them well I would expect
in the Judiciary Committee everybody's
going to read the Privacy notices but
but as far as the consumers who were
protecting
um my guess is probably many of them
don't so having some guard rails down to
make sure that companies are providing
clearly understood and clearly
recognized privacy notices that are easy
to get to right at the top of uh of an
agreement is uh is is really important
for for Consumer Protection so like I
say this doesn't have everything that
that house bill 536 had in it but it's
got a lot more provides I think more
definition and uh and certainly is a is
a very good first step to codifying uh
privacy rights in New Hampshire so
thanks for that I think there's probably
a lot of people that are that are be
able to answer more technical questions
but I'm happy to take any any questions
from any members of the committee
I guess representative I just have one
question and it may and it may be that
other people could answer this more
fully than you but just just generally
since you have been involved in this for
a while do is there the the main thing
that I had as a concern and I'm not I'm
not suggesting that I'm opposed to the
to the bill but the one thing that I did
sort of concern me was is the
is the cutoff of what businesses are
covered
um is it are you satisfied that the
cutoff of I think it's a hundred
thousand account that that's appropriate
should it be higher are we is there some
is there some chance that we would be
um
imposing sort of undue burdens on
smaller businesses that that's really my
goal yeah so that's a that's a that's a
really good question and and you know I
think the cut line is appropriate on um
uh on that and I think the the
exclusions that uh that the bill makes
are also appropriate because we do have
some some statute that does protect um
uh personally identify information when
collected by government agencies
departments schools things like things
like that
um and um and that was certainly one of
the concerns that we had back in 2019
and uh and and the bill that was
introduced back then did not establish
any cut line nor
provide any guidelines to um to
companies and businesses on what to put
in in their contracts so uh but but it
but it it exposed those businesses to
what the consumer
um felt was what they agreed to when you
know signing up for ancestry.com or
23andMe or whatever it happened to be so
so I so I I think this this you know you
could probably wiggle that cut line
around based on how the um uh the
committee feels but but I think it does
establish
uh guard rails that um uh that that
clearly Define what um you know what's
what's expected and as Senator Carson
said it is being used in other states
right now and um and and companies are
complying with uh with this now this
just clearly puts it now you know as
rights protected in um in New Hampshire
law
thank you uh other questions for this
Witness
yes
yeah thanks um actually just following
up on the question that you just asked
um when I was reading this I was
wondering in this section
was it intended that this be a hundred
thousand consumers within New Hampshire
or 25 000 within New Hampshire or in
their entire scope of of uh business
yeah not the great question that one's
beyond my pay grade so so um I I think
the um the the folks here from some of
the companies who have who who have
testified on this bill in other states
as well that have that have adopted uh
this language could clarify that
other questions yes representative
Horgan
thank you of course there's a lot of um
there's a lot of apps which use uh
personal data you know you basically you
give them at least a limited set of your
personal data in exchange for the
service like today I of course it was
probably unnecessary because you think I
would know my how to get here by now but
I use for example ways to
um to on my way to the uh on the way to
the state house which then keeps track
of
keep track of where I am hopefully
hopefully de-identify in a way that
would be hard for a hacker to to steal
and then partially of course they had
the attendees it had the implications of
all the other cars on the road for the
purpose of telling me what the traffic
conditions were and then also frankly
apparently even though oddly ever paying
attention to him the occasionally
so that there's a question yeah so will
these services like that still be able
to operate where their business model
will still be able to work um if if we
pass this law yeah yeah I I think so and
thank you for the question
representative Horgan I I I think so and
I think what you've the examples that
you've you've laid out here actually
illustrate why a law like this is so
important because um you know as and you
know I mentioned earlier even when when
you know a lot of new cars you have to
agree with their privacy agreement
before you can even use them but but as
as automobiles become more advanced and
drive themselves they need to know where
they're going they know where you are
they're collecting that date that that
data along the way from the time you
leave your driveway or in front of your
house to the time you get where where
you're going and um and and it it's it's
another example of of how personally
identified data is being and and is
being collected by companies and is
being used by companies to improve
products to get you places safely and
things like that and uh and and it's
going to be essential you can't even use
some of these products without without
agreeing and and agreeing to that data
being collected so um so uh uh you know
I think you know in the end of the day
it's um it's going to make our products
better it's going to make people safer
and um and and you know and companies
are going to they're really going to
have to comply with this
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you very much
next I'm going to call on uh uh
representative Sean philiot am I
pronouncing that correctly
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is representative
Sean filio I represent the residents of
Chester Chester district 7 which covers
Keane's Ward 2.
as has already been covered this bill
would provide New Hampshire residents
with important digital privacy rights
I think it's important to discuss what
this bill would do and what it wouldn't
do
this bill would help New Hampshire
residents to join the residence of a
number of other states enjoying digital
privacy rights which already exist in
those States
important to mention here is California
this bill has existed for a number of
years in California and why that matters
is that anywhere that a California
resident could potentially engage in
digital Commerce this bill applies so if
a business could potentially reach a
California resident
that business has already needed to
comply with this law
so if that business could potentially
reach a California resident that
business for years now has already had
to pull it put into place the digital
architecture to comply with this that is
to find somebody within its online
database to be able to give that person
a copy of their digital information and
then to excise that digital information
if somebody needed it now this bill only
applies to larger online businesses that
is an online business that has the reach
of a hundred thousand people or an
online business that has a reach of 25
000 people but at least a quarter of his
business is engaging in the creation of
online information
so to answer the first question if this
applies to businesses with a reach of a
hundred thousand people that is a
hundred thousand people in the aggregate
but at least one of those would hit in
this bill a New Hampshire resident or in
the case of the California Bill a
California resident
so in the case of the California Bill
why that matters is virtually every
single large online business
would have the potential of hitting a
California resident because it's our
nation's largest state economy
so they've already had to comply
therefore this bill is asking for
nothing new of these businesses
because they've already been complying
we're just asking now that New Hampshire
joined the list of states that allows
their residents to be able to ask that
they have digital privacy rights
and these are important rights
if you go online and you buy something
you've created a digital Trail
these businesses know something about
you
've given your email address but it
doesn't end there
the business then follows you online you
create digital breadcrumbs because it
doesn't stop at that website
they follow you online beyond that
website
you started by buying a pair of shoes
but then
you go to a recipe website
that shoe website follows you to the
recipe website and then you go to your
news website whichever News website you
prefer
they know about that too and it
continues
if you'd prefer that that information
not be kept or if you at least want to
know your digital breadcrumbs this bill
is the way to get that information
or to delete that information
other states residents have that right
and we're requesting the New Hampshire
residents have that right too
the ability to get that information and
to delete that information already
exists for these large businesses
we're not asking so that something
newbie created we're asking that New
Hampshire residents get that right too
now this is only for large businesses
we're not asking that the small local
coffee shop that happens to have a
website be required to do this this is
for large businesses only
so you're a small business doesn't need
to do this
is it possible that a new business may
be captured within the scope of this
bill
yes
but
the ability the architecture to be able
to comply with this already exists there
are already now a number of businesses
that help businesses to comply with this
so the ability to comply with this bill
already exists there are digital
custodians that could help businesses to
be able to comply with this readily
because fortunately we are now following
another State's footsteps so the ability
to comply with this bill is readily
available we're not creating something
new we fortunately have the advantage of
following in other states footsteps
with that I'll take any questions that
yes representative Schmidt
thank you
um Mr chair
so are you saying that these large
entities have the ability
to
answer those requests
in States X Y and Z including California
but would refuse to answer that request
if
it came from someone in one of the 40
plus states where they do not have this
law are they going to
say control the traffic and say yes
we'll answer your request but no we
won't answer
another request
thank you representative for the
question that would be their option to
decide whether or not to comply with the
request in the 40-something states that
do not currently have this in place it
become ultimately a business decision as
to whether they decided to comply with
that request or not
I think would be a poor business
decision but it's a business is a
decision not a legal decision thank you
other questions for this one yes
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chair I have a number of questions but
I'm going to save those I have one
question specifically where in the build
does it say applies to businesses with a
hundred thousand people or less where
can you just point to the language
it's section 507 H2
um per second
that is it thank you and the technical
know-how we both uh I think have the
same question my technical know-how is
oh okay uh representative Stapleton I
think you had a question
thank you for taking my question
these uh digital breadcrumbs is that the
same as the cookies that we can control
clean out and eliminate off of our
computer or is that another Factor
uh that part of that would be that
digital know-how that I do not have part
of that would be cookies and as you will
see many websites ask you whether or not
you want them to collect cookies
that is part of actually their
compliance with the California law which
has required you to opt in or opt out of
cookies
that is fortunately part of that
California and all law now that is that
they're complying with uh and part of it
is your creation and deletion of cookies
uh that you can opt in or opt out of but
it goes beyond that as well um and there
are people who are more digitally savvy
than me that are sitting behind me you
can also probably answer that better
than I can
yes follow up
so the cookies are the front end that we
can control we're given notice on but
these digital breadcrumbs are kind of
like in the background in a database
reserved in the cloud whatever that and
that's what the bill is trying to
penetrate for our control to
uh thank you representative in part and
I would and then as I've said there are
people behind me who will be able to
give more digital know-how but uh
they we would there are elements to this
Beyond just simply cookies that are
collected as well even something as
simple as you entering your email
address into a website you'd be able to
ask that they no longer have that as
well
thank you
that's a great representative Terror
yeah just um I think this is a general
question
what would trigger this since it is the
Attorney General's option to to pursue
um something under this is does there
need to be a back-end system for people
to sort of report what they think are
violations of this or or is there going
to be some sort of a a process for
um reporting or somehow uh certifying
that you're complying with this
I'm not sure if I follow the question
I'm sorry
and sorry if maybe it doesn't make sense
but I I was wondering uh since it is the
right of the State Attorney General to
pursue actions under this this law
what do you foresee being the trigger
that sort of creates that is there is
there a new mechanism for consumers to
file complaints or is the attorney is
there a reporting mechanism I was just
curious like how you envisioned this
sort of raising to the level where that
would actually happen
thank you for representative so there
are a number of provisions of the law uh
what I focused on here are the digital
are the consumers digital privacy rights
one of which could be that if simply a
digital custodian were to foolishly
refuse to comply with a
a consumer's request a consumer could
report that to the attorney general
which would be a violation of the
state's consumer protection act at which
point the cons attorney general would be
able to decide whether to pursue that or
not I think it's unlikely the Attorney
General would pursue a single violation
but it would then go into the Attorney
General's information and uh repeated
violations may be pursued as well uh
for example another provision of the
bill is that a
digital custodian also needs to
make make aware that if whether or not
they are giving information to
advertising information to third parties
if a website were not to comply with
that provision the Attorney General
could pursue that as well as a violation
of the consumer protection act so
different versions of the ACT if the
Attorney General believed that it were
to rise to the threshold of unfair and
deceptive practices if it were to be
egregious enough or repetitive enough
the attorney general and his discretion
could decide to pursue that
other questions for this Witness
thank you for taking my question uh
uh the the question I would have is how
would the consumer
communicate with the digital
processor or whatever you you call these
companies
uh thank you representative each
company would have a different means of
being able to uh communicate with them
some may do it through email or an
online form or you could simply go
through the traditional method of Simply
writing a letter as I've seen it done
through the California act typically
it's an online form or email
follow up go ahead
is is that
method of communication specified
somewhere in this bill
not that I see it in the bill because it
does provide not specifying when the
bill does allow for that leeway for the
company to decide what is best for that
company it also allows the consumer to
have that leeway to provide what the
consumer prefers as best for that
consumer if a consumer were to want to
write a letter simply because they don't
want to have any further digital
communication with the company that
would provide that leeway as well
uh thank you other questions yes
representative divine
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um there was a company recently on that
well-known company uh that was held
accountable
um in in one of these cases where it was
I think selling
um people's information or passing it
along so then they would end up
receiving emails ads what have you and
they were kind of going against us how
would a consumer be able to
um you know if they know that they're
getting xsa emails and they opted out of
something and they were getting
um uh
how would they be able to
stop that from happening even though
they might have opt out is there
anything in this that would help the
consumer to be able to opt out of those
things or who do they reach out to if
it's not in the terms and conditions on
the company's site
thank you for representative this would
at least provide a first step to the
consumer to be able to understand where
their digital information had gone by
tracking their digital trail from at
least one digital custodian to
understand how their information had
been used
it wouldn't stop everything in its
tracks but it would be an important
first step
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir
thank you chairman
next gonna call on uh Ryan Harkins uh
good morning
correct is that working thank you my
apologies uh good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is Ryan
Harkins I am senior director of public
policy with Microsoft and I'd like to
thank you for the opportunity to testify
we support SB 255 and we would encourage
you to pass it
we at Microsoft have long taken privacy
seriously
and we have been at this for some time
we first started calling for a federal
comprehensive Privacy Law in this
country in 2005.
and 18 years later we still find
ourselves with no federal law on the
books and with much of the rest of the
world
racing ahead to regulate data protection
and privacy and Technology
and as technology has become
increasingly important in all of our
lives and as the amount of data that is
being generated about each and every one
of us has grown
it has become clear that there are real
and serious concerns that the public has
about what all of that means for our
privacy
and it's also clear
that the public has lost trust in
technology and in the technology
industry
and in our view
there is an urgent need to pass new laws
in order to help start earn that trust
back laws that would both provide
consumers with the rights that are
necessary to control their personal data
and laws that would provide clear rules
of the road to business and to Industry
to allow us to continue to innovate with
certainty and with confidence and so for
several years
we have been supporting efforts in the
states
which in the absence of leadership from
Congress have have stepped up to start
passing privacy laws to provide their
constituents with protections
um
there are in our view
a number of components that need to be
part of any Privacy Law
in order to ensure that it will both
provide business with clear rules of the
road while also providing consumers with
real incredible protections
this bill contains those things first
it is important to have strong
definitions
and in particular it is important to
ensure that the definitions of data that
will be covered by the bill and that
will not be covered by the bill
um
ensure that the bill will apply to the
kinds of modern online data sets that
are used to track and Target consumers
today
that means that the definition of
personal data for instance needs to
cover not just identified data
meaning data associated with say your
name
or your mailing address or even your
email address
but identifiable data
data that can identify you indirectly
because it is stored in association with
a cookie ID
or an IP address
or some other form of persistent unique
identifier
this bill has strong definitions that in
our view would ensure that it will apply
to Modern online data sets that are used
to track and Target each and every one
of us on the internet
second it has to provide consumers with
the rights that are necessary to empower
them to control their personal data
that means the right to transparency to
know and confirm that companies are
collecting personal data about you the
right to access your personal data the
right to correct it the right to delete
it
the right to Port it in other words to
take your personal data if you are doing
business with Microsoft and you decide
that you want to do business with
another company to take the data that
you have provided to us and take it to a
different company
it also means uh the right to consent to
different forms of data processing in
this bill like other laws that have
passed across the country
takes an appropriately nuanced approach
to consent it would both provide
consumers with the right to opt out
of certain sensitive processing
activities meaning the collection
sharing and use of your personal data
for data sales for targeted advertising
for certain types of automated profiling
it would also require companies at a
certain point to allow consumers to
exercise those rights with something
that you can think of as an easy button
so meaning some people refer to this as
a global privacy control or a universal
opt-out signal
but the idea is that you could go to
your web browser
or onto your phone and click a button at
one place and one time
and opt out of those activities for
every website that you will visit across
the internet rather than requiring
consumers to go to every single website
to exercise that right individually
it also would provide consumers with
opt-in consent rights
requiring companies to obtain opt-in
consent in order to collect share and
use sensitive data so data like
Biometrics or geolocation information
so providing consumers with rights to
control their data
third
it would impose affirmative obligations
on companies irrespective of whether
consumers actually exercise rights
to be responsible stewards of the data
they collect
and that would include obligations like
transparency
data minimization
the obligation to provide appropriate
and reasonable security safeguards and
also the obligation to conduct and
document risk assessments of data
processing activities that may give rise
to an increased risk of harm to
Consumers
and those assessments well they the
topic may seem dry and boring they are
in our view an important component of
privacy laws because they will require
companies to professionalize the way
they treat data
to ensure that they are being thoughtful
about their data processing activities
to engage in good data hygiene
and they will provide if you will a road
map for the Attorney General a peek
under the hood if you will as to what
companies are actually doing with data
and those assessments will need to be
made available to the attorney general
upon request if they are relevant to an
investigation
so
in conclusion I would thank you for your
leadership
um and your your interest in attempting
to move this issue forward
um again we support the bill we would
encourage you to pass it and with that
I'd be happy to try and answer any
questions you may have questions for
this week is representative page thank
you Mr chair I have a real Hardball
question did you submit written
testimony and I apologize if I missed it
I have not my apologies I have not
submitted written testimony but I will
follow up
um with a copy of my remarks to submit
to the committee
other questions representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm looking at um page five
um line six section two the following
information data shall be exempt from
this chapter I'm looking all the way at
K uh collection maintenance disclosure
sale communication any personal
information being bearing on a
customer's credit worthiness credit
standing credit capacity but then it
goes to character General reputation
personal characteristic or mode of
living
by consumer reporting I guess I'm
wondering like in what way would
Microsoft need to have or have
information exempt from this chapter
that has to do with the consumer's
character General General reputation
well I would say with respect to all of
these exemptions in section that section
two like these are not exemptions that
we are taking a position on these aren't
exemptions we are asking for these
aren't exemptions we're opposing
um based on our reading of the bill
the rights and obligations in the bill
would apply to Microsoft in our
activities
part of the challenge in attempting to
pass a comprehensive Privacy Law like
this
is that the United States for decades
has taken a very different approach to
data protection and privacy than what
this bill and and other laws like in
California
Virginia Colorado Connecticut Utah and
now Iowa have have passed
for decades the United States has taken
a laissez-faire approach to privacy and
data protection but we have had narrow
sector specific or industry-specific
privacy laws on the books so you're
pointing to one the Fair Credit
Reporting Act we've also have the Grammy
bliley act which applies to privacy in
the financial sector we have HIPAA and
the high tech act which applies to
privacy in the healthcare industry we
even have you know something called the
children's online privacy protection act
or Kappa
which addresses the collection of
personal information from kids under 13
online
that approach is very different from the
approach that our friends in the
European Union have long taken
in which they have dating all the way
back to 1995 when they enacted something
called the data protection directive
have had a broad comprehensive approach
to privacy and data protection
so in one place in one law by and large
they apply and address all privacy
issues across all Industries and sectors
the data protection directive was was
updated by the general data protection
regulation or gdpr just a few years ago
something you may have heard of
so
in our view we need in this country to
move towards a comprehensive approach to
privacy and data protection
it is clear to us that the sort of
narrow
sector-specific approach it no longer
works
and the question is how do you
transition to that kind of approach
given that we have all of these other
laws on the books
um
is the approach that this bill or that
other laws have taken to try to Grapple
with that problem perfect probably not
but we think this is a great first first
step
um and a great start in the right
direction
yes representative griesen thank you Mr
Sharon thank you sir for uh providing
your testimony here is this law required
in order for Microsoft to be able to
implement these very same things as its
own internal policy to protect its own
personal customers no it's not and
you know Mike as Microsoft I can tell
you that when the gdpr passed and became
effective in the European Union we
committed publicly that we would apply
the protections the rights at the heart
of the gdpr to consumables consumers
worldwide
when California passed its law
the CCPA in 2018 we subsequently said we
will apply the Protections in that law
to Consumers across the entire country
but in our view it's not enough to give
business and companies the option of
whether they're going to protect
consumers and comply with those sorts of
safeguards
in order to really start earning back
the trust of the public we need laws
that just make it clear
that everyone will abide by the same
rules
other other question yes uh
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman
um as I understand
Microsoft is solidly supportive of the
principles in this
in this uh bill
um all out of concern for the consumer
can you then help me understand
in page 16 of my my copy
um line 31 nothing in this chapter shall
be construed as providing the basis for
or be subject to a private right of
action for violations under this chapter
those two lines follow
um
the previous section which lists six
possible
uh requirements for the Attorney General
to consider before it would agree
to process a complaint
and I don't understand
why if the purpose is to meet the
protection provide the protectors for
the consumer why this specifically
eliminates consumers right to be able to
file a complaint
thank you for the question
representative
I would say if we step back for a moment
that there is no issue which has done
more to derail and prevent
the passage of privacy laws good privacy
laws then the question of enforcement
and whether a bill should contain a
private right of action
that issue more than any other killed
efforts to pass comprehensive Privacy
Law in our home state of Washington for
four years running
and unfortunately that question
quickly becomes incredibly polarizing
and to different folks across the
political Spectrum on that issue it
becomes something of a religious issue
if you will
there are folks in the business
Community for whom anything that is
redolent of a private right of action
sends them running for the Hills
there are folks on the other side who
insist that any Privacy Law or any other
law for that matter needs to have a
extremely broad private right of action
with statutory damages and class action
liability for technical violations of
Allah irrespective of whether there is
actually any harm at issue in the case
and so what we have said and have been
saying to lawmakers is
we don't want to be involved in that
discussion and that issue we don't think
it's productive for us to try to be
involved in that discussion
we think it's up to policy makers in the
state to determine what would be
appropriate and what would be a strong
and effective and appropriate means of
enforcement we want to see good privacy
laws pass
um and we think this is a good Privacy
Law and we hope that it passes
other uh representative Anders
thank you Mr chair and thank you
excuse me taking my question
how is a consumer
going to trust a company if they ask
that their information personal
information be deleted
without going through an attorney
general which is just going to create
Havoc because if thousands of people
want the Attorney General wondering if
their Privacy Information has been
deleted or not
how can we trust a company and what I'm
trying to say is how do we know a
company's not just hiding that data
I think represented that is a very fair
question and I think the first step in
establishing that trust is to impose
obligations in law
to in fact for example delete someone's
data if they ask for it to be deleted
that obligation does not exist for New
Hampshire residents today in law
there's no obligation for for companies
when they receive a request from a New
Hampshire resident to delete that data
um the law does provide that companies
need to provide transparency about what
they are doing with data that would
include in my view responding to
deletion requests
it would require companies to provide a
secure and reliable means of allowing
consumers to exercise their rights
and it would require companies to
document the sort of data processing
activities that they are engaging in
including responding to deletion
requests in Impact assessments which can
ultimately be made available to the
Attorney General's office and
is that is that perfect I don't know is
there more that a law could do perhaps
is this a good first step I think the
answer is yes
and
the other thing I might say is that look
I'm not an expert on
um
you know the New Hampshire
consumer protection act and and I'm not
it's been a long time since I've
litigated any cases of any kind
whatsoever
but my view of this bill
is that it would not remove any existing
rights that that New Hampshire consumers
may have to file lawsuits today
um and so in my view
um to the extent New Hampshire residents
you know some states provide consumers
with the ability to file lawsuits
alleging unfair deceptive conduct under
their consumer protection acts my view
is that to the extent that those rights
exist for New Hampshire residents today
and I don't know whether they do or not
they or or they don't
this bill would not take those rights
away
it also would not take away existing
rights that consumers may have to bring
lawsuits under the sort of common law
privacy torts that have long existed in
this country
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Perez
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my questions
this is a law to me that what it really
does it has no consequences it's totally
dependent upon the attorney general
and what consequences he feels would be
appropriate
that's the only thing that concerns me
it's you know it's like
if you speed there's a financial
consequence okay if there isn't I'll go
as fast as I want to go
I don't see in this
the end when it says enforcement
is this bill enforceable and in other
states are they providing more
consequences or enforcement of the bill
is that something we should look at to
see if perhaps one of the things that's
hard to do after you pass a bill is to
put the enforcement in afterwards
it's easier to take it out than it is to
put it in so our other state saying if a
company does this and they are found to
do this then this will happen to them
because we're not saying that here thank
you thank you for the question
representative I would say at the outset
that we absolutely support strong
enforcement and think that enforcement
has to be a component of a strong data
protection and privacy regime in order
to hold companies accountable if they
violate the law
um most other states have provided that
enforcement will be done by the state
attorney general
and and oftentimes it is either
um or or pursuant to the attorney
general's authority to enforce say their
State's udep or consumer protection act
which is the approach taken by this bill
um California
has gone a step further
and has created an entire new agency the
California privacy Protection Agency
designed to some extent on similar data
protection authorities that exist in
each country in the European Union which
are responsible there for
enforcing just the the gdpr or that
country's Privacy Law so that is the
approach that California has taken and
you know they have provided that agency
with rule making Authority and resources
in in lots of things to help it enforce
the law and even issue regulations
um
that's not an issue that I would pretend
you know I would not pretend to know
what will work for a particular State
um I think it makes sense to provide in
in there is a need absolutely to provide
uh regulators
who are going to be responsible for
enforcing a law with resources they will
need to enforce the law but but I
wouldn't pretend to tell policy makers
what those resources should be given all
of the other priorities that that you
all deal with on a daily basis
yes
thank you
so the other states that were mentioned
I believe it was Connecticut and several
States so to your knowledge none of them
have
fines or written penalties or
Consequences to not following their laws
there may be fines I would have to
follow go back and double check those
laws and if you would like I'd be happy
to do that and provide more information
um I know that
um and so they may expressly spell out
you know the penalty is going to be X
number of dollars per violation I know
that based on the discussions that I was
a part of in Washington state you know
again a bill that didn't pass but that
there were different versions of that
bill that either expressly listed the
fines in the Privacy bill or simply
referred to
um the fines that currently exist under
Washington State consumer protection act
but if it would be helpful I'd be happy
to follow up with it shouldn't be hard
to to pull I'd be happy to follow up
with that information yes representative
child
excuse me thank you for taking my
question
um
it's not possible
to have a website be different to comply
with each State's individual law as more
and more States passed consumer
protection laws
so I'm wondering about isn't the
standard going to de facto become the
state that has the most stringent or
most consumer protective
statute
and I'm wondering about that and I'm
wondering also whether just by its sheer
size
California will become or is or will
become the de facto standard and then
also I'm just wondering I mean I'm sure
we all use
california-based websites Apple
obviously
um and I I wouldn't have known that
there's an opt-out consistent with
California law
um
so I'm just wondering about that just
about your experience about that also
thank you yeah thank you representative
I mean you would think and would hope
that perhaps all companies would simply
align to whatever the strongest privacy
State Privacy Law is and just apply that
across the country
but there is a lot of money in data
and I think the reality is that gives
incentives to companies to differentiate
and to not provide protections to
individuals if they aren't legally
obligated to do so and there are
techniques that companies can use
whether it's through IP addresses or
otherwise to try and identify
where residents are located and
therefore to apply different protections
to them
so
I think it's also
fair to point out that
this this law which is or this bill
which is based substantially on the law
that passed in Connecticut
and is based upon a framework that was
originally developed by a man named
reuven Carlisle who was a senator in
Washington State
that framework was initially an effort
to take what California did in 2018.
and to go further
but to do so using Concepts and
terminology that ultimately come from
the European Union's general data
protection regulation
and therefore to both provide consumers
with more protections and more rights
than California law was providing
but to do so in a way that is clear and
more concise and using terms that
businesses who were already doing
business outside of the country were
already familiar with and therefore
in our view not only more protective to
Consumers but also easier for companies
to comply with
now the reality is that subsequent to
California passing their law the CCPA
California voters updated their law with
a ballot initiative the California
privacy rights act that ballot
initiative in my view
brought California law substantively to
um but the Frameworks while they arrive
at a very similar substantive place the
Frameworks are different and there are
some significant ways that in my view
this bill is is more privacy protective
California law for example gives people
with the right to opt out of data sales
and the sharing of information for
purposes of targeted advertising
this law would provide people with the
right to opt out not only of data sales
but of the processing meaning any
collection use sharing Etc of data for
targeted advertising so in my view the
op.right is broader
this bill would provide people with the
right to provide opt-in consent and
would specifically specifically provides
that companies cannot use dark patterns
or in other words efforts to deceive
people by the way you design your
website or your consent experience in
order to get you to consent
but with the right to opt in to the use
of your sensitive data so data like
Biometrics geolocation information race
ethnicity religious beliefs Etc
California law provides people with the
right to notice and opt out of that data
collection so
in any event again I I think that this
law this bill in California law arrive
at similar places there there are a
number of ways in which I think it is a
superior approach representative page
did you have a question representative
uh representative Horrigan if you have a
question
um thank you if we the committee choose
to go forward with it um I understand
why
the California laws in your view the
strongest at least the first law is
passed and the strongest and of course
it's a senator of high tech but on the
other hand we had a debate recently
about electric vehicles and actually the
argument against was basically
this this is a California this is a
California California standard this is a
California law so how has that been a
problem in in the other states like your
own home state of Washington state and
um just so how do we how would we sell
it to the full house if we go forward to
this if it's since we may lose some
votes simply by the magic word
California
well this is I guess from that
perspective fortunately this is not
California and I'm not sure I would say
California law is the strongest in the
country I think that there are some
people who would argue that I think that
there are plenty of others who would
argue that Colorado and Connecticut
which their laws are very similar that
they are the strongest privacy laws in
in the country so look I I think if
you're trying to sell this bill to your
colleagues in the house
the pitch is that this bill would both
provide consumers with the rights that
are necessary to control their personal
data
while also providing businesses with
clear rules of the road so that they can
continue to innovate with certainty and
and with confidence and to do so frankly
in a way
that is interoperable with other laws
that have passed not only in the United
States but also I think to some extent
with international data protection laws
like the European Union's general data
protection regulation all right
representative
hi there thank you for taking my
question isn't it true that New
Hampshire has a consumer protection act
that would allow for the AG to enforce a
penalty if this were to be violated
yes my understanding is yes thank you
thank you for taking my question uh are
there any states that have laws that
just have a outright ban of the
collection of personal digital personal
Digital Data
no
um and
I in our view like that would not be a
good thing because
um personal data can and is can be and
is used for a lot of really beneficial
purposes to provide the public with
products and services that it wants
um to conduct research and and other
things and I also think that if you'd
passed a law that
simply prohibited the collection of
personal data
um
you would also run into real challenges
with the first amendment's protection
for freedom of expression
thank you yes uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for taking our questions uh on page
seven
lines 19 beginning in line 19 of this
bill this is information provided in
response to a consumer request shall be
provided by a controller free of charge
once per customer a consumer excuse me
during any 12-month period does this
mean that a consumer would have to
submit annual requests to have their
information removed or deleted uh and
and is the controller obligated to
eliminate this data for a one-year
period of time I I guess my question is
is is is if if they can be charged a fee
or they can be denied due to excessive
or repetitive requests how long is a is
is a company uh required to
to conceal this data or delete this data
so in thank you representative and so
this was I'm sorry I was trying to find
the provision this is Page seven line
19. yeah
um
so I think a couple of things I think
one
um
this bill importantly says that
consumers have the ability to exercise
these rights and to do so free of charge
um could you simply provide that they
have the right to do so free of charge
and eliminate the requirement that that
right only applied once during any
12-month period you could sure
um but I think you know what is
important is that
the bill would also to the extent that a
company determines that that someone is
harassing them
and is submitting multiple requests
um you know for for
to to harass or for whatever reason that
the company then Bears the burden of
demonstrating that those requests are in
fact manifestly unfounded excessive or
repetitive in nature I think that
you know this provision arrived at the
place that it is in Connecticut
um be out of a desire to try and balance
both
providing consumers with the ability to
exercise their rights easily
and in Freely
while also ensuring that companies are
not subject to
undue requests or excessive burdens and
trying to comply and respond to requests
and I think that that is less of an
issue for a big company like Microsoft
which has lots of resources at its
disposal and more of an issue for
smaller companies which would still be
subject to the the provisions of the law
representative
a question yes thank you Mr chair
um two if I if I could is Microsoft
already operating more or less in line
with the provisions in this chapter
yes okay so would Microsoft be okay if
we removed
um section four of the enforcement that
would
nothing in this chapter shall be
construed as providing basis for subject
to a private right of action
I would say that we are we support the
bill as written and and we are not
taking a position
um on enforcement we support the bill as
written
all right other questions for this
Witness
yes representative Stapleton
thank you for taking my question
the um question brought up by
representative Grecian was interesting
because
the one-year uh
pre-exempt uh for a request seems to
parallel what is already taking place in
the credit industry and credit reports
and I don't know how many years that is
but uh there probably is some federal
law behind that which impelled that so
a lot of this seems to be
um
there's underlying statute and law
already in place on a lot of this stuff
is there not
there there are
um yes there there are laws and
Provisions on some of these things that
address some of these issues in a way
that is consistent with the way this
bill would address them
um
I do think that this bill would go much
further than existing law in in clearly
providing consumers with rights among
other things
um but the concepts that are in this
bill
um aren't new
and and do exist in say other
comprehensive privacy laws that have
passed across the country
um in other laws around the world like
the general data protection regulation
other representative Terror
yeah thanks and thanks for taking this
question
um I guess my my question and let me
Focus specifically on page 10
um lines starting on line 34
um section 2 B I guess
um
I guess there's there there's an adage
that if if you're not paying for the uh
paying for the product then you are the
product which seems to be part of this
discussion but not really sort of clear
um if someone exercises this right to
remove their data am I reading in this
section and I don't know if this is true
currently or not but that it would be
possible then to
uh begin charging consumers essentially
for the service that their data would
otherwise be
um
used to provide for free I know that's
the business model of a lot of online
entities these days
um and I couldn't tell if this section
was meant to either open the door for
that or clarify but it seems to suggest
that if you opt out you could then be
you could set up a system where you
would then be charged for the services
so the the the Bill thank you for the
question
um it's a good question the the bill
does provide that businesses cannot I
believe I was trying to find the
specific provision but but cannot
discriminate against consumers for
exercising their rights
um it does also attempt to balance that
with efforts to provide people with say
loyalty programs or
other forms of programs in which data
really is a part of the transaction and
in programs which provide direct benefit
and value to the consumers so think that
loyalty program that you may have at
your grocery store
um and in
provides or attempts to allow those
kinds of programs to continue to to move
um or or to operate so I think the bill
does a good job of trying to
balance those two things
um
again I would say in general
is it perfect does it does it get it
absolutely right I don't know
um but but I think it lands in a very
reasonable place can I just have one
follow-up on that yes so did I
understand you to say that that this uh
prohibition against discrimination would
essentially in your in your
understanding
prevent companies from just basically
saying well if we can't if you're not
sharing your data with us then you have
to pay for our product as opposed to the
loyalty programs and the other sort of
sort of that is that's my reading okay
yes other questions for this Witness
so I I guess I just have one question on
the on the application section
um where it says
um that it's limited to 100 and I'm just
quoting here controlled uh
or process the personal data of not less
than 100 000 consumers I guess what I'm
wondering is
that's there's no time frame there is
that right so in other words if I'm a
small business and I process
10 000 consumers this year and 10 000
different consumers next year and you
know in other words do I get cat 20
years from now do I get or 10 years from
now do I get captured by this
um
where I you know even though I'm a small
business and and I guess what I'm
wondering is should it say 100 000 per
year for example
that is I believe that is what most
other bills have or laws have provided
that this is on an annual basis
um I agree Mr chair as I'm looking at
the provision I don't see those words on
the page
um and so
if they're not in the bill somewhere
else I mean that seems like a reasonable
addition
um
you know the the the thresholds on the
companies that this would apply to in
terms of size Etc is not something that
we have gotten super involved with just
because it may surprise you to find but
Microsoft isn't a small business
um and but but I do think in principle
it makes sense to provide sort of
exemptions so that you're not
overburdening your local dry cleaner or
coffee shop and and those sorts of
things can I just ask where a follow-up
is is the the the limits that are in
this bill of a hundred thousand and and
then the second one of 25
000 uh and not derived more than 25
percent uh from sale are those the same
as our our in the Connecticut Bill and
and the Virginia Bill uh and the color
uh I think it was Colorado or or the or
are the numbers different in those
States I would Mr chair I would have to
follow back up with those
laws to confirm whether they are in fact
identical
um I believe they're similar
um you know and and
are those numbers right for a state like
New Hampshire I I don't know
um you know and I'm not sure we would
have a position on what the numbers
should be exactly as long as they
weren't so high that you know we are
some of our peers would would not be
covered by the law right you know I
think it would be helpful to us if you
could if you could if somebody could
just get us what the numbers are in the
other states that should that would be
helpful other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you
you know I saw Senator Susie come in but
then she left it she
she had to leave again I'm sorry so um
uh I note that we are now uh 15 minutes
over the time we were supposed to have
started the hearing on the next bill
um I but this is important and so we're
gonna we're gonna keep going the only
thing I would ask is as future Witnesses
come up if if you've heard somebody has
already covered a point um we really
don't need to hear it like two or three
times so I just ask if you keep your if
you could keep your remarks as brief as
possible and I'm next going to call on
Brandon uh garage I hope I'm pronouncing
thank you Mr chairperson members of the
committee my name is Brandon garad I am
the chief of the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau at the Attorney
General's office and the attorney
general I'm here today to speak on
behalf of the Attorney General neither
in support of or against this bill but
in order to point out some concerns that
were brought to the attention of the
Senate that still exist in its current
form at its core you know this is a bill
where we certainly take no issue with
the intent behind it it is a
pro-consumer bill it is comprehensive it
contains definitions that it is
technically for the most part
enforceable
subject to some issues that I'll get to
in a minute but for those of you
normally when bills you know come that
impact New Hampshire's consumer
protection act they appear in Commerce
um and so I always appear at you know
house Commerce Senate Commerce at the
beginning of the year to give an
overview of New Hampshire's consumer
protection act and what the bureau does
and the reason for that is because every
time something is added to New
Hampshire's consumer protection act
something new is defined as an unfair
interceptive act or practice
a real consideration that needs to be
thought through is the issue of
resources and who is going to if you you
could pass all the laws you want and
they can be perfect and comprehensive
and well-defined but if you don't have
the Manpower and the resources to
enforce that bill depending on the
amount of the number of complaints and
the you know amount of work that it's
going to take at the end of the day can
be essentially toothless so New
Hampshire's Consumer Protection Bureau
has exclusive authority to enforce New
Hampshire's consumer protection act with
the exception of there's a private right
of action that applies not in this bill
which I'll get to in a moment but which
applies to essentially all other things
that are defined under the consumer
protection act as unfair and deceptive
Acts or practices but as far as state
enforcement anything that is defined as
an unfair and deceptive act or practice
falls on the Consumer Protection Bureau
to review those types of complaints
investigate those complaints and if
appropriate prosecute those complaints
through either civil or criminal
enforcement action
that as it currently stands results in a
tremendous amount of work that is
accomplished by not a tremendous number
of people the bureau just in its unfair
and deceptive Acts or practices work
receives about
4500 complaints and inquiries a year we
have a consumer protection hotline that
is manned entirely by volunteers they
serve as an initial Shepherd of those
calls to basically try to if it's you
know an inquiry that's not going to be
an unfair and deceptive act or practice
we tried to send them elsewhere or to
another appropriate state agency but if
it is something that you know arguably
could be an unfair and deceptive act or
practices I personally along with the
paralegals in the bureau review every
single one of those complaints and make
efforts to resolve every single one of
those complaints we are successful
sometimes oftentimes we are not and if
we are not able to Simply resolve it
with the back and forth of the business
it falls to the bureau through only two
invest Gators and about nine lawyers to
issue subpoenas to take depositions to
conduct interviews with witnesses to try
to build cases in order to actually go
to court and enforce these laws to hold
these businesses accountable and it
currently takes a tremendous amount of
work and that unfair and deceptive Acts
or practices work is only a small
segment of what the bureau is actually
responsible for it's the consumer
protection antitrust Bureau so we're
also responsible for all of the state's
antitrust enforcement work I'm sure it's
no secret to any members of this
committee that in recent years New
Hampshire's Health Care system has faced
an enormous amount of attempted and
successful in some cases consolidation
Massachusetts hospitals coming into New
Hampshire to to buy our Hospital Systems
make us part of their systems every
single one of those Hospital
transactions and other transactions is
extremely comprehensively reviewed for
violations of State antitrust laws by
oftentimes you know just one or two two
members of our Bureau that are committed
to doing that work full-time
the bureau is also responsible for
reviewing annually compliance with
consumer protection laws for every
health club in the state of New
Hampshire every martial arts studio in
the state of New Hampshire the bureau is
also responsible for reviewing and
approving compliance with State consumer
protection laws for every single new
condominium that is sold in the state
every subdivision that is offered for
sale to the public in the state we're
also responsible for representing the
state's second injury fund we are
responsible for New Hampshire's tobacco
enforcement work which results in a
significant amount of money to the state
each year and you know also are
responsible for have a very robust elder
abuse and financial exploitation unit
that criminally investigates and
prosecutes some of the most serious
cases of elder abuse and financial
exploitation in the state
and we're able to accomplish that with
the resources we have but even with the
resources we have we're limited to only
taking those cases that are the most
serious
um and the rest we defer if it's
criminal to the you know County
attorneys or local prosecutors to do
that work or you know if it is a civil
matter we often tell consumers you know
you have a private right of action so if
it's a it's a smaller violation a single
violation consumers have that ability
um to share the the burden of consumer
protection enforcement with this bill
and the reason I point all this out is
that this bill has the potential to
create an enormous amount of additional
work for the bureau which I think
realistically to do would require
additional resources in the bureau both
in the form of attorney
investigator and potentially a paralegal
as well and I know that since my
testimony in this regard before the
Senate there have been conversations
about potentially adding some of those
resources to the bureau but I think it's
critical that as members of this
committee decide whether to make this
part of New Hampshire's consumer
protection act and place this
responsibility on the Consumer
Protection Bureau of the AG's office
that you understand that in order to
meaningfully do it and be able to
accomplish the type of protections and
enforcement of these protections that
you're attempting to create for New
Hampshire consumers it would take
additional resources in order to
meaningfully accomplish that
especially because
um as was pointed out earlier this bill
the drafters have made the decision to
eliminate the private right of action
that is present in all other unfair and
deceptive Acts or practices cases that
can currently be brought in the state
so like I referenced earlier if so if
you have a single complaint you know one
consumer complains and says hey this
company is
um violating is get engaged in unfair
and deceptive Acts or practices maybe
it's a contractor used car dealer
something like that if it's a one-off
complaint it's not a lot of money
unfortunately based on limitations on
resources we're often in the position of
telling the consumer this is something
that you'll have to pursue on your own
by bringing your own private unfair and
deceptive Acts or practices case we
can't do that in this case because the
private right of action has been taken
away so every single violation of this
bill if it becomes law that's reported
to the Attorney General's office will
either be prosecuted by the Attorney
General's office or won't be prosecuted
at all there is no ability for us to
share that burden with others and you
know obviously there there may be
reasons for that decision but I think
the the reality of the potential for the
increase workload would demand
additional resources in order to be able
to do it effectively and you know there
was a comment that was made by a
representative earlier that you know it
would be unlikely that the Attorney
General would choose to pursue a single
violation of the statute if it was
reported and I just want to point out
that that is not necessarily true and
especially if the violation if if we
have a reported violation of law that we
enforce and only we enforce and if we
don't have the ability to say you know
here are some other resources or here is
you know your ability to seek Justice on
your own it places Us in the position of
either ignoring a violation of law
altogether or investigating it so you
know we really cannot look the other way
if a company is violating New Hampshire
law especially if the consumer who's
affected in that regard has no other
recourse anywhere else based on that
value Nation
so I do think you know will we prosecute
every single violation probably not but
if a single consumer
if this bill is passed if a single
consumer files a complaint with the
bureau and says hey I've made a request
that my data be deleted from this
company we would have an obligation
based on our responsibilities as New
Hampshire's Consumer Protection Bureau
to at a minimum review that complaint
look into that complaint bring that
complaint to the attention of the
business and if they ignored it they
ignored inquiries from us we'd be left
in a very difficult position of deciding
you know either we're going to ignore
this altogether or we're going to bring
a lawsuit in order to make sure that
they comply with New Hampshire law that
responsibility is one that we take very
seriously and one that requires a
significant amount of manpower to
accomplish
so
I think that for the most part is my
testimony as it pertains to resources I
do also want to point out one
inconsistency ambiguity in the
enforcement section of the statute that
I brought to the attention of the Senate
that in my opinion still exists and I
think it's a really important one
located on page 16.
I'm looking at line 19 through 24. it's
basically two sections that govern the
requirement of the Attorney General to
provide 60 days notice in an attempt to
cure before bringing any action for a
violation in this matter so if you begin
on line 19 Roman 2 I'm just going to
quote this the attorney general shall
prior to initiating any action for a
violation under this chapter issue a
notice a violation to the controller if
the Attorney General determines that a
cure is possible and if the controller
fails to cure such violation within 60
days of receipt of the notice of
violation attorney general may bring an
action pursuant to this section so as
that section as I read that section it
gives the
whether or not the attorney general has
to issue a 60-day notice and opportunity
to cure is entirely determined by
whether the AG in our opinion believes
that a cure is possible
but then in the following section Roman
3 beginning on line 23 it says in
determining whether to Grant a
controller or processor the opportunity
to cure an alleged violation described
under this chapter there's a number of
factors that the Attorney General's
office may consider and they really
don't relate to the ability to cure in
fact many of them deal with potential
harm to the public the complexity of the
size and complexity of the processor the
number of violations nature and extent
of controller or processors processing
activities substantial likelihood of
injury to the public safety of persons
or property this seems to give us
factors that we can consider in
determining whether or not we need to
bring or we need to give them an
opportunity to cure where is the prior
section says that the only factor that
we can consider is whether the Cure is
possible I see those things as extremely
inconsistent and would basically put us
in a position of feeling that we needed
to issue a notice of attempt to here
every single time because I I don't know
it's hard and I'm not an expert in this
by any means but it's hard to imagine a
violation that wouldn't be in any way
shape or form curable
um so so let me just ask you a question
sure if we were to change section two uh
to from Shell to May and if we were to
end that first sentence so that it read
so that it read the Attorney General May
prior to initiating an action for
violation under this chapter issue a
notice of violation to the controller
period
and take out the thing about if it's
possible to cure we just read if we left
it like that and then left three and
that would make them consistent I think
that would solve the problem
okay all right
I'm sorry you I didn't mean to interrupt
you but I just wanted to catch that
before
I appreciate the question and it was
very well timed as that was the end of
what I had prepared to say but happy to
take any questions from any members of
the committee
questions yes representative stapled
thank you for taking my question
um
you guys got a lot of work to do and it
sounds like the the bucket of work is
full at the brim already so when I look
at the financial note and it's got zeros
in it and indeterminable was there a
communication gap on this bill relative
to your input to finance to provide some
better estimate of cost relative to the
immense amount of additional work that
is possible here
I don't think it's an issue of a
communication breakdown I think it's
more I think it's important to
understand how we approach fiscal notes
when we receive a request for them so
anticipating the amount of increased
work
that this bill will result in isn't
possible we don't know there could be a
thousand new complaints a year there
could be zero you just don't know and so
the number of resources that it will
take to carry out these obligations are
indeterminable at the time that we're
giving the fiscal note what we do is we
look at a bill and we try to ask
ourselves the question does this have
the potential to significantly increase
our work and do we have the ability to
measure what that increase will be if
you know if it requires something like
you know the AG now has an annual report
that it needs to make and it's a once a
year thing and it's you know
quantifiable as you know we just have
this one task that we can assign to one
person to complete once a year you
probably don't need additional resources
to do that you probably can find you
know a way to shift things around so
that one person can write that report
but when you're talking about adding a
whole new category especially I mean
this is an entire new chapter that would
now be the responsibility of the bureau
any violation of this chapter in any
form would be our responsibility to
investigate uh to respond to and to
potentially prosecute or litigate if we
couldn't you know solve the violation
otherwise
it's impossible to determine what those
numbers of dollars that you would put
into you know human beings to enforce
this would be at this time we just don't
know
yes representative Smith
thank you
um rather than a lengthy response I
think you could also point out to my
colleague that in the fiscal note at the
end of the methodology section you say
the department assumes due to the
complexity of the review it would likely
require significant additional resources
so while you have zeros listed above I
think you make very clear in the
methodology that this is not going to be
for free that's right other questions
for this witness yes representative
Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
sure are there any
um
are there any options that you might be
receiving more
help in your department
again so I'm not privy to these
conversations but the information that
I've gotten from
um some folks higher up at the Attorney
General's office is that since my
testimony at the Senate there have been
conversations specifically about adding
additional resources to the bureau to
address this issue I don't know what the
state of those conversations are or the
likelihood that they come to fruition
but I know the conversations are at
least taking place
yes representative cutoff
so if we both added in a clause to state
that
a private right of action would be a you
know available under this as well as
adding in
a potential fine of some sort such as
the the consumer protection act
currently has I think there's fines
differentiating in there I think it's
between a thousand dollars or ten
thousand dollars if there was some sort
of fines like I guess that would help to
pay for additional Staffing would you
agree that those two things may kind of
fix
the struggles that you're having
so I would disagree with that and the so
the the reason I disagree with that is
the way the bureau is currently funded
through a consumer protection escrow
account that is 100 funded by the
Consumer Protection Bureau and the work
that we do when we have fines and
penalties or settlements with businesses
all that money goes into this escrow
account and it pays for the salary of
every single person in the bureau but
there's a five million dollar cap on any
given time on that escrow account the
rest goes to the general fund so no we
can bring as many enforce and it's
always full
um so we could up the amount of money we
bring in we wouldn't see an extra dollar
of that in order to fund another
position it would go to the general fund
and you would need to create the
positions in order to be able to so
funding them is one problem but also
just creating the positions is another
so we don't currently have any positions
that we would have the opportunity to
but I would like to actually just
clarify one other thing to make sure
that everybody understands
um and I should have said this earlier
the reason that there's no specific fine
in here is the the way so in 358a which
is New Hampshire's consumer protection
act it says that any unfair and
deceptive act or practice committed in
the course of Commerce shall be
violation of the statute and then
there's rights and remedies in that
statute if there's an unfair and
deceptive act or practice that's
committed in Commerce it includes a ten
thousand dollar civil penalty uh per
violation that can be brought so this
statute like many other statutes that
have been brought is not specifically
it's not going to live in 358 a but it
Loops it back and says a violation of
this chapter like many other laws on our
books like the health club statute that
I talked about earlier the condominium
statute that I talked about
um not the condominium sorry but health
clubs martial arts several other areas
Loop it back and say any violation of
this chapter like this chapter is an
unfair and deceptive act or practice so
the Civil penalties for unfair and
deceptive Acts or practices would be
applicable to a violation of this
okay so two two follow-up things if I
may thank you for taking my question so
I guess the first one would be that we
could create those positions right and
we could also increase the cap on that
you know from the current 5 million
um and then the second part of that
would be so if everything kind of links
back to that consumer protection act
then would a private right of action be
available already under the consumer
protection act or is that specific part
excluded but the ten thousand dollar
fine isn't excluded great question I'm
really glad you asked so
358a includes a specific section that
creates a private right of action for
unfair and deceptive acts for practices
that are committed in Commerce and the
remedies are different so you get
certain remedies if you're a the state
bringing this case and then there's
different remedies if you're an
individual brain so under the consumer
protection act
a private right of action exists and
there's a defined set of Remedies but
the way this statute is worded is
specifically says that nothing shall be
construed to create a private right of
action for the enforcement of this
section I think that that is very strong
evidence that the private right of
action in 358a would not be available as
currently worded if this bill were to
although it would be an unfair and
deceptive act or practice if you violate
it this bill is enforced exclusively by
the attorney general and there is no
private right of action it basically
creates an exemption to the private
right of action in 358a and says the
violations of this chapter would not be
subject to that prior right of action
other questions for this witness see
none thank you very much thank you
you're next going to call on Karen uh
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Karen soucy I'm
here on behalf of the XI and Finney
Capital group and we are representing
ctia that is the Wireless Communications
Association
I've submitted testimony of Jake lestock
who is employed by ctia but certainly
not going to read that I'm just going to
summarize their position
um
we understand certainly that
data and privacy of that data is very
important
we have concerns that as we move forward
um
that we're approaching state by state
regulations
which can become very burdensome and
confusing when it comes to compliance
for these providers
we certainly
um
support the federal efforts that are
ongoing right now
but again we understand there is a
vacuum there's a void right now and that
steps from states are moving forward on
their own all that we simply ask is that
when you consider moving this
legislation forward
that you seek probably the Connecticut
model is my understanding based on
conversations with the providers that
you try to align it as close as possible
to that model again we're just seeking
questions questions for this witness yes
representative Alexander thank you it
was under my impression that this bill
was the Connecticut model is that
correct it's my understanding that it is
very close to it I don't have the
information to specify where it Strays
from the Connecticut model but again the
providers are seeking as close to that
as possible it would be helpful if you
could send that information over to us I
certainly will thank you
other questions for this witness saying
none thank you thanks
good morning chairman Lynn in committee
members I am Rick Fabrizio director of
communications and public policy for the
business and industry Association New
Hampshire Statewide Chamber of Commerce
I submitted my testimony previously so
I'm just gonna going to offer a brief
synopsis of that
Senate Bill 255 was crafted with
industry support which assure helps
assure practical regulation of Commerce
it exempts smaller businesses protecting
them from compliance cost most simply
cannot afford to bear
it is closely modeled on legislation
recently passed in Virginia Colorado
Connecticut Utah and Iowa which just
passed their law last month all five
laws are very similar and form an
emerging consensus of what should be in
a comprehensive Privacy Law
aligning State legislation in the
absence of Federal Regulation will make
compliance easier for businesses engaged
in interstate commerce
by passing Senate Bill 255 New Hampshire
can achieve a long-sought comprehensive
Community data Privacy Law that balances
consumer and business interest with the
confidence it is past muster in the five
previous States based on some of the
remarks that we've heard today clearly
there are opportunities to improve this
legislation I would point out that the
Connecticut Law to a question earlier
about the exemptions of the 100 000 25
000 that is based on the prior calendar
year
um and also in Connecticut
violations would default to their
consumer Privacy Act which has uh fines
or violations
not unlike what the situation would be
in New Hampshire I'm sorry as a private
right of action it does not have a
private reaction right of action as Ryan
Harkins had pointed out that one of the
biggest stumbling blocks to pass in
comprehensive comprehensive privacy Acts
is the private right of action so while
there may be improvements made to this
bill if it does not Advance New
Hampshire will not have a comprehensive
data protection act and consumers will
still lack those protections I'm happy
to take any questions you may have
questions for this Witness
seeing none great thank you thank you
um Andrew
kinshaw I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly uh from uh
State privacy and Society coalition
is that better
um represent the state privacy and
security Coalition uh we're a coalition
of 32 companies and uh uh over six trade
associations uh representing a wide
array of sectors from Automotive to
retail to technology to Telecom
we work on these in in all 50 states and
I have a background as a privacy
compliance attorney helping companies
work through various State privacy laws
we have written testimony which which
I'll submit uh shortly after this here
we do support uh the bill as written and
would ask that no changes be made to the
the substantive Provisions here instead
of going through my testimony I thought
it might be helpful to answer some of
the questions that have come up
throughout the hearing particularly as
they relate to thresholds you know the
other states to your question Mr chair
about what the other states do the
hundred thousand consumers uh in a
calendar year is very very standard
across all other states at this point
there are some differences around the
that second set of thresholds with the
revenue and the number of consumers the
states differ a little bit there but
that hundred thousand is fairly
consistent we would not necessarily have
a position on that we think that that's
an issue for States each state to
resolve on its own but just for
clarity's sake wanted to point that out
representative Alexander your question
about the the fcra exemption that
language about reliability and consumer
behavior that comes from the definition
of a consumer report from that act so
that's why that language is there just
reinforcing that I want to be clear that
that this law would be stronger than
California there's been a lot of talk
about the comparison today for some of
the reasons previously mentioned but
California's law does not have an opt-in
for sensitive data it does not require
at this time data detection assessments
and so and and you know really
importantly this bill is much clearer
and easier to read and we believe that
when bills are clear compliance
increases right businesses don't have to
hire privacy attorneys uh to tell them
what it means they're able to read the
bill and implement it so you know we
believe that this is a stronger model I
think the other the other issue with
California's laws that it is really a
moving Target and it's constantly
changing this bill is built to be
sustainable over time and be a framework
that can adapt to new technologies and
new issues that arise but to do so in a
way that is comprehensible both to
Consumers and to businesses so we feel
uh that this bill provides actually a
stronger approach it is based on the
Connecticut model which I think is is
generally excuse me considered to be the
the strongest State Privacy Law in the
country three this bill in in New
Hampshire is at the cusp of of passing
what would be the eighth state to to
pass comprehensive privacy legislation
we've already seen uh Virginia Colorado
Connecticut uh in Utah pass uh recently
Iowa has passed Indiana's bill is
sitting on the governor's desk we also
expect Tennessee Montana and Texas to
pass a version of this bill as well in
the in the coming months here so
um you know I I think I live in this
region I think it also makes sense to
follow Connecticut and that having a
regional approach makes a lot of sense I
know how closely intertwined the the
economies in in the Six States in New
England are I think it makes a lot of
sense for uh New Hampshire to adopt the
Connecticut approach and be a leader in
helping New England move to a model
where
businesses that operate in between
states are able to do so with consistent
expectations and those of us who are
consumers who frequently travel between
states can do so with consistent
expectations of what our privacy rights
are as well
um questions uh yes representative
so I know that you stated that the
Connecticut model would be a good model
to follow and that
they were using a hundred thousand
annually as their Baseline for it
however you also stated that you don't
want any changes made to this
legislation I just wanted to point out
that this legislation does currently
just say a hundred thousand and it
doesn't Define annually so it could be
in virtuity sure and I said to to the
substantive provisions of the bill we
wouldn't ask for any changes so if this
committee or the state wanted to change
that language I think that's perfectly
fine to to move to within a calendar
year that's pretty consistent with what
other states are doing other questions
for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir next
I'm going to call on Matt Schwartz from
chair Vice chair and members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
testify today my name is Matt Schwartz
and I'm a policy analyst with Consumer
Reports uh if amended in a few key ways
we do support today's legislation
in our view privacy legislation that
relies on opt-out model such as this
bill
uh must add a minimum include the
provision for Universal opt-out
otherwise consumers are forced to
navigate an untenable complicated
ecosystem of privacy notices opt-out
requests and verification on an
individual basis with each of the
businesses that they interact with
which is a number that that could be in
the thousands section 507 h42
and 507 H5 of this act addressed this
issue by requiring that covered
businesses allow
consumers or their authorized agents to
opt out from a controller's processing
of their personal data
privacy researchers and Advocates and
Publishers have already created the
technology
that would fit the bill for an
authorized agent under this act
including the global privacy control
as well as Consumer Reports its own
permission slip app both of which make
the opt-out model more workable for
consumers
however we do suggest a few tweaks to
improve the protections of this bill
our main concern at this juncture
relates to attorney general enforcement
of this bill uh several weeks ago
and again today we heard from the AG's
office who testified that they would not
be able to enforce the bill uh given
current resources
given that our two policy
recommendations in order of preference
would be to either include a private
right of action in this bill
or barring that or in addition to that
include substantial new Appropriations
to support robust AG enforcement
we also suggest that the drafters remove
the right to cure from the attorney
general enforcement
section otherwise businesses can kind of
break the law with no punishment so long
as they respond to an AG request within
I believe it's 60 days in this
legislation
which would only further strain the he's
ability to stretch its resources and
enforce this act efficiently
without these changes there would not be
meaningful accountability mechanisms to
back up the substantial requirements in
this bill
we have a few other recommendations that
are further specified in our written
testimony I'll just go over them briefly
given the time surface in your written
testimony I think we will read that but
I yeah okay thank you
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
um next I'm going to call on Matt Lenz
thank you chair members of the committee
uh my name is Matt Lenz I represent BSA
the software Alliance BSA is the leading
advocate for the global software
industry our members are business to
business companies that create
technology products and services that
other companies use uh including Cloud
Computing Services and workplace
collaboration tools I know that you are
running short on time here so I want to
let you know we provided written
testimony uh yesterday we submitted that
so you should have that uh our four
major points and I won't go into detail
but basically really support the bill uh
appreciate the sponsor's approach on the
controller processor distinction why we
have members that are controllers we
have many of our members are the
processors uh so we represent sort of
the process or provision of this bill uh
really support the bills uh goal of
interoperability with other state laws
we think that's very important in uh
promoting a consistent approach to
Consumer privacy uh and we do support
the current enforcement mechanism
through the Attorney General's office uh
in our testimony we do request one
change related to subcontractors right
now it gives the ability for a
controller to object uh to a
subcontractor we would prefer that that
would be a provision to notify uh the
controller when a processor uses a
subcontractor we do that because uh
processors could use dozens of
subcontractors when there's an issue
that comes up related to a security
breach or a conflict Etc so it makes it
a little bit funky to try to uh try to
do that in a timely space with that
happy to take any questions questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir next
I'm going to call on David M
um
right yeah from Minneapolis
hello
don't present anybody so if I want you
to First tell us what your name is
please sure of course they didn't know
it sir David Miller okay thank you
um I work as a privacy engineer I'm out
here on behalf of any employer or any
clients I'm simply a concerned citizen
that
is very interested in the series of
privacy laws modeled after California
and Connecticut and the European Union
uh regulation and would like to be of
any assistance that I can
as a technical worker who implements uh
privacy uh regulations and also has
experience as a pen tester meaning that
I have worked in European companies in
the European Union prior to the passage
of gdpr and I can testify that with a
lack of strong and clear Financial
incentives like the four percent of
global annual turnover maximum penalty
offered in the gdpr
uh European companies and European
subsidiaries of American or
International companies were not
minimizing data as had been required
from the 1995 data protection Direct of
the European Union and so I would like
to thank the representatives here who
have voiced concern about the bottleneck
created uh by the lack of a private
right of action except through the
Consumer Protection Bureau uh by the
discretion of the Attorney General to
pursue cases and by the lack of a kind
of clear uh Financial penalties offered
by the California referenda as to how
this bill would actually be treated by
the uh
um companies responsible for
implementing the restrictions and
auditing of their own behavior
additionally
um I think it was representative Manos
um the companies sorry representative
Andrews uh voice concerned about whether
the companies could actually be expected
to delete data after the facts
um I appreciate uh Mr Hawkins
um testimony that uh the the passage of
any law about this would be helpful to
ensuring that the uh that the companies
would have some obligation
to minimize data but I'd like to point
out that
um from auditing experience in the EU
there is a lack of likelihood that uh
enforcement would be feasible and I'd
like to if anyone has any questions
questions for this witness
representative yes
so are you would you be in support of
this bill if it allowed for a private
right of action I would in that case yes
I'd like to mention to the committee uh
a couple of things uh one of them uh is
that uh
the U.S approach to Privacy Law while it
has to respect certain First Amendment
constraints mentioned by Mr Hawkins like
the right to collect and redistribute
data not this prevents the US from
taking a strong approach as a European
Union but the European Union approach
has been to make all collection
processing and redistribution of data
for valuable consideration or any other
purpose subject to opt in whereas the
Virginia Connecticut and New Hampshire
proposals are opt out while we can't
take so strong a stance it's my
understanding that the reason that a lot
of the internationally operating U.S
tech companies are interested in getting
more and more states to have privacy
regulations is not just for the
confidence of U.S consumers but to
ensure that their businesses overseas
are not disrupted
because
the exchange of data with their U.S
servers and their U.S subsidiaries
requires that the European Union not
sanction them and uh the agreements made
uh between uh the uh U.S Department of
Commerce and the European Union have
been struck down a number of times as
not meeting the standards of European
law especially in light of the Snowden
Revelations so um with respect to
representative uh manus's uh question
about whether tech companies in the
United States would in as more and more
States passed privacy laws simply opt to
implement the strongest of them what
we've been seeing instead in civil
society and just by watching uh the
progress here is that simultaneously
there's a game going on here where uh
the lobbyists with all due respect to
all of you
um uh are coming to a lot of State uh
hearings in order to push these various
bills
possibly in the hopes that a federal
bill would be modeled on the middle or
weakest of these and therefore I
encourage you all when considering the
wording in this bill in its comparison
to other states
that one may play into this ensuring
that a federal Bill if passed
um protects the rights of New Hampshire
consumers as much as possible rather
than relying on another State's
regulation to play that role right
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir
thank you uh Neil Kirk former
representative
good morning Mr chairman excuse me
good morning or good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record I'm Neil Kirk I live in Ware
and I'm representing myself and yes I
was a former representative for many
years
um
I would like to say I come in support of
this bill because I've been very
concerned about privacy for decades
but unfortunately I cannot
this is one of the most complex pieces
of legislation that I've seen
and today while your questions in the
testimony
got into this it merely scratched the
surface to really understand this bill
will take a great deal of time
and a great deal of effort by either a
subcommittee or a study committee
and I hope you will do that because the
ramifications and I don't understand
this fully myself need to be understood
and is usually the responsibility of a
house Committee in the legislative
process to make sure that that happens
um
the bill does a few very important
things but they're very small and con in
comparison with the total interest of
privacy it does give a person
well let me go on
um
in section H3
that's on page four line 31.
there is a whole slew of exclusions
There are 16 types of data that are
excluded Health Care banking
Etc
and there are
um six entities kinds of entities that
are excluded uh non-profits Higher
Education Health Care and government
so this really applies to a relatively
limited group of organizations because
so much has been Exempted
um
the Privacy notices required by this
bill are important
but there are problems with them first
of all they're very complex
and secondly every company is going to
have its own
now if you're like me and you go through
you go to a website
you just don't have time to read the
Privacy notices and to read all of the
terms and conditions
now we're going to have other options if
this bill were to pass
and they would be different for each
company
and it would be very difficult for us as
a practical matter
to know that they exist and to take
advantage of them
at the very least
this bill needs to be modified so that
whatever the format of opt-in and opt
out and get information is going to be
offered to people as meeting their
expectations of privacy it's done in a
uniform way and very simply so that
people can see it and act immediately on
it and that we don't have to think that
every time we go to a website we have to
do a different investigation to find out
what our rights are and how we can
um
as has been noted there's a problem with
this bill because it's enforceable only
by the AG and because there are no
Financial penalties
and as somebody pointed out the AG has
to give an opportunity for correction
before it he can take any action so
the incentive for me as a company is to
do business as usual and if I get caught
okay I'll correct what I've done that
doesn't make sense and I hope this
committee will will change that a
private right of action would be very
important because after all I feel that
I've been offended by this action of a
company but the AG doesn't for whatever
reason either because he doesn't have
resources or he and I disagree I want to
take my my concern to court I can't
not under this bill
that that I think needs to change too
um
this bill is
an an opt
well I'm not really sure whether it's
opt-in or opt out
public policy should favor
and opt out as a default so that our
data is protected unless we choose to
give the company the right to use it
the Assumption behind this bill is that
the data that we give a company doesn't
belong to us anymore it's the company's
data and they can do with it what they
want and this bill says wait
we the companies will give up that right
in certain circumstances because there's
a tsunami of concern about privacy and
we don't want consumers to be very upset
so we'll make it possible for consumers
to control their own data
my thought is that if it's my data and I
give it to the company I give it to them
for a particular purpose and for that
purpose only and if they want to use it
for some other purpose
then they need to ask me
so I would do a 180 on this bill
not that the companies would like that
of course because there's money to be
made from data which is what this bill
um
in fact can I can I just interrupt and
just ask one question sure Mr Kirk isn't
there
isn't there a First Amendment concern
about the
uh about what you propose that in other
words if when you say it's when you say
it's my data I mean let's just let's
just take a very simple example if I
tell you if I if I tell you a secret and
I say please don't tell that to anyone
do I do can I restrict you and you say
yes I won't tell anyone can I restrict
you from telling someone or is that or
would that be a First Amendment
violation for it for for the law to say
you can't now tell anyone
um
I don't think it would be because if it
would be then this bill would also be a
first violation a First Amendment
violation because it's in effect
interfering with the communication of
data the state is saying this is allowed
and this is not allowed
uh I I think that we're not I I don't
think it's a First Amendment issue
because we're not saying what you can
and can say we're only saying what you
can do with this data
um we're saying and we have this as a
state policy in other areas that um for
example your medical record according to
state law
is your property
it's not the property of Dartmouth
Hitchcock or Dr Jones it's your property
um and that's information and we're
saying this and my proposal is to use
that same concept here I don't see the
First Amendment issue
but Mr chairman I defer to your
expertise in this area
um if I may proceed please yes thank you
um
because the bill has it backward I think
the title is somewhat misleading it's
not really an expectation of privacy
it's the protection of information in
the hands of businesses
or just one aside because it occurred to
me now Mr chairman you asked whether the
hundred thousand people uh is is New
Hampshire or Nationwide if you look at
the definition of consumer in this bill
and that's the word that's used 100 000
consumers a consumer has to be a
resident of New Hampshire so that's one
hundred thousand New Hampshire people
roughly one out of every 13 people
probably Amazon qualifies Microsoft
qualifies but it's just going to be
major national companies I would think
that would qualify uh or would be
subject to this bill everyone else would
not be subject to it so while they're
very important in our lives they are
certainly not the majority of companies
either in this state or nationally who
would be subject to this bill
um
the committee
I believe needs to fully understand this
bill before it acts on it that's house
practice that's the legislature's
strength
the Senate doesn't always have the time
or manpower to do it the house does I
hope that you will do it
I personally doubt that a subcommittee
could do this in the time available
before this bill has to be out of
committee so my suggestion is either you
retain it to work on it or that you set
this up set up some sort of a study
committee that will go into this whole
subject and deal with the issue of
opt-in and opt out and whose data really
is it when I provide information to a
Company for purpose a and the company
decides to use that information for
purpose B and either tells me
or doesn't tell me but if they don't if
they do tell me I don't have a choice at
the way things are now
um I guess my concern with this bill is
that it violates my basic concept of
personal information and that is it
belongs to me and I should be able to
control it and when I give it to
somebody else I give it to them for a
specific purpose and for that purpose
only and for them to use it for some
other purpose in effect denies me of my
property right in my personal
information and I'd like to get paid for
it among other things
and with that very subtle uh conclusion
questions I'd be pleased to answer any
questions questions for this word
thank you seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman all right uh
we're considerably over the limit I
don't have any other cards is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
Senate bill 255.
all right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on Senate bill 255.
and
I'm going to now open the here I'm going
to now open the hearing on Senate
Whoop I'm I'm 255
oh
yeah sure you know what um we're going
to take a two minute break so that we
can some people that
are here on the last bill can leave and
people that are here for the next bill
can
oh
I I'm we're back in session and I'm
going to open the hearing on uh Senate
Bill 65 and represent uh recognize uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for taking my testimony
um excuse me for the record my name is
Regina bartzell I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 19 which
encompasses the towns of dairy Hampstead
and Windham
and I'm here to introduce oh and I'm
also chair of Health and Human Services
which is why I am here I'm here to
introduce Senate Bill 65 for Senator
Bill Gannon who can't be here today and
I urge you to support the bill as
amended by the Senate
I have also communicated with Senator
Gannon and he is uh he supports the
Senate position which is the repeal of
RSA 519-b
this bill repeals 519 RSA 519-b which
was enact enacted back in 2005. it
enabled the screening panels for medical
injury claims along with the original
legislation a legislative study
committee was enacted that met every
year until 2018 when it's Sunset that
legislative study committee received
regular reports from the New Hampshire
Department of Insurance
and the judicial branch including data
and findings we've studied the medical
malpractice screening panels for almost
20 years
there is nothing we will learn in the
next three years that we haven't learned
in the last 20 years studying this issue
um the testimony we heard that the
panels are simply not working and never
have at the Senate hearing the committee
heard extensive testimony that for
almost two decades the medical screening
panels had been in place the panels have
not been widely used have not met any of
the promises made and have not reduced
the number of medical malpractice cases
filed and have not decreased the costs
for the involved parties
most notably we heard about the vast
resources that it costs our judicial
branch to process these
um
these cases the committee heard
testimony about the extensive time and
effort the judicial branch puts into
assembling these panels only to have
them waived at the last moment by both
plaintiff and defense counsel the panels
are simply not working and therefore the
Senate on a bipartisan basis unanimously
agreed the time has come to repeal the
panel system to reduce the cost time and
effort to all parties involved in the
medical malpractice cases I will also I
won't
um
read
read I also attached with my testimony a
letter from uh David Bettencourt from
the Department of Insurance Senator
Bradley in the testimony had asked him
to kind of do a summary of all the cases
that they had and I gave you the the
sheet the letter that he had drafted or
the memo that he had drafted but in
synopsis our analysis shows that the use
of the screening panel process did not
appear to have any measurable measurable
effect on the outcome of the claims when
it came to the length process and he
goes into detail in bullet points on
some of the some of the issues with it I
will also just quickly go through some
bullet points Richard head had testified
in our committee he said that it was
apparent to the judicial branch that the
screening process had failed and is not
a functioning process he also said that
judicial branch initially proposed a
full repeal of the medical malpractice
practice screening panel Stitch statute
at a meeting with the New Hampshire
Medical Society Hospital Association and
the association for justice he also said
the number of panels has considered
consistently been between zero and four
for the last decade he said that he
feels embarrassed for the staff who have
to go through the effort of pulling
together a panel only for the panel to
be waived at the last moment and what
I'll finally say is Senator Bradley did
ask summarize for Richard head it says
Senator Bradley summarized Mr head's
testimony as if
as if Mr head had his druthers the
medical malpractice screening panels
would be repealed in their entirety and
Mr head said that that was correct that
that was what the judicial branch
proposed in the first instance
so with that thank you for the
opportunity to speak and I will take any
questions although I know you're running
behind and there are plenty of people
behind me that know the subject much
better than I do thank you questions for
yes Senator yes representative Horrigan
thank you very much being um being
waived and I noticed there's some
numbers about it from about
a former representative pedicure
commission Deputy Commissioner
bettencors are they waiving
because they decided to go to the court
instead are they waving because they've
settled um out of panel instead of out
of corridor because
or because the plaintiff is abandoned
the claim so like why are they
what are the main reasons why they're
being waived and
well I think that's a better question
for the attorneys but I have a my
suspicion is that there'd be a waived
because they either came they have a
resolution or they want to take it to
the courts or sometimes from my
understanding some um the attorneys who
are presenting the malpractice cases
don't want to don't want to
give any idea of how they're going to be
other questions for this Witness
say none thank you very much Senator
thank you
next I'm going to call on Abigail Alby
I guess it's good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Abigail Albee I'm here on behalf of the
Superior Court
um I'm here to tell you that we support
the repeal and ask if you have any
questions that I can answer I'm I'm
going to be very brief I'm just here to
answer any questions that you might have
perhaps about how the panels are working
or not working
um and so I'll open it up to you guys if
you have questions about how the
superior court is functioning currently
with these
you know I wonder might what might be
helpful could you could you just sort of
take us through what the
what is entailed and say a new
malpractice claim is filed sure what can
you take us through the process sure so
when a new um malpractice panel or new
malpractice case is filed there's sort
of two routes that it's simultaneously
on the first route is the panel route
which means that
um it goes to an office that's
supervised by the Chief Justice of the
New Hampshire Superior Court tiananetto
and that office opens up a case
um that case is then a panel is put
together the panel consists of a
chairperson who's normally a retired
judge an attorney
usually someone from the Healthcare
Community a doctor an expert in the
field in which the medical malpractice
claim is brought
um so that is one piece that is going on
on the other channel that is happening
the case is usually is being filed in
the Superior Court the case is still
headed down the trial track and so we're
putting resources towards a trial
setting up structuring conferences
setting up
final pre-trials setting up jury
selection all the things that would
normally happen while the panel process
is also going on so I'm not sure if I
that completely answers your question
but there's sort of these two tracks
that they're both on at the same time
and what we're what we've seen over the
course of this almost 20 years as the
senator was just testifying to is that
the
panels are being mostly waived by but
both sides of the litigation
so what happens is we have this as I
said the first track where everybody is
getting ready for the panel as well as
getting ready for trial and so the
lawyers on both sides both for the you
know for the doctors and for
um the plaintiffs are being put in a
position where they're preparing for two
set tracks of litigation essentially a
litigation track that involves the panel
to discuss if they can be resolved and
then also
can you just tell us a little bit about
what is there in your experience or in
the Court's experience is has there been
difficulty in trying to get both doctors
and lawyers to serve on the panels yes
um yeah the short answer is yes
um I I would say that you know it's a
Time con consumption for both sides
right for lawyers to volunteer to be on
these panels and for
um the medical community to also be on
the panels it is a big time draw for
them they have to review a lot of
documents they have to be prepared for
the panel hearings and so it has
traditionally been very difficult for us
I think in the beginning we had a lot of
not a lot but we had a number of panel
hearings and we it was I think
working the way it was intended to work
but over the years that has completely
dwindled
um so much so that we've had a very hard
time to get people to sit on the panels
and also even you know most of the
panels have just disappeared I believe
and I don't want to
um assume but I believe that no I don't
know if this was what Richard submitted
Richard had to the um Senate when he
testified or if you have a copy of the
the numbers but there are we have all
the numbers of the day with the data the
dates back from 2005 to today
um and I'm happy to provide that to you
if you don't have it but we I believe it
was provided yeah well you know what
actually yes yes saying to me I have not
I will circulate it I have not done that
yet and I should have but um I will
circulate it to the other members of the
committee okay so I can say that
essentially since 2017
other questions yes representative Tripp
thank you for taking my question
excuse me could you you said that the
panels have been waived what does that
mean
so under the the current
um statute any party can waive the panel
or both parties can waive the panel
which means that they can say you know
what this is not a good use of our
resources not a good use of our time or
strategic for strategic reasons they may
say they don't want to have the panel
because
um you'll see that in the statute it
allows for
um
the findings the panel findings to be
submitted to the jury if you go to a
jury trial the findings are submitted to
the jury so lawyers May opt to say this
is not a good strategic decision for my
case to go to a panel Hearing in which
case they would say I'm gonna we're
gonna wave it we're gonna go straight to
the jury or go straight to the court to
resolve the issue
other questions for this one is yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair how much do you
um I'm right here
how much do you believe the judicial
branch will save with the repeal of
these
we have at least one position that is
completely dedicated to this I will
that's my limited knowledge to how much
money that would cost in the sense that
I don't I can't give you a dollar figure
I'm happy to get you that information
but I don't know that off the top of my
head other than to say to you that I
know for from my current role that
there's one position that definitely
deals exclusively with this
um so sorry not a great answer other
question representative Perez
so the committee was not the only way to
settle something without going to trial
correct correct so I'd be curious since
2017 how many or what percentage of
cases were settled going that route
without going to trial
meaning going to I'm sorry just
demeaning going to the panel as a
settlement or going a different route
for something following the court route
the traditional traditional
and we're settled before they actually
went to a you don't have to tell me
right now I just would be curious
actually we're settled without having to
go before a jury okay is that clear it
is and thank you I can I can tell you
that my rough math which is exactly that
rough math because it's not my strong
suit
um is
about 60 cases settled by a voluntary
non-seater docket markings before a
panel hearing and then the TR and beyond
that there were
um
you know 50 or so that were dismissed
withdrawn
um summary judgment mistrial so that's
all before juries before a jury is
impaneled yes
and I I just need a perspective out of
how many
350.
2017 to 2020.
so 2017 to 2020 there were how many 350
would so there were okay I I'm sorry so
yeah 275 cases roughly in that time
period that were filed with the court
for medical malpractice across the state
sorry
um that there were about 105 where the
panels were waived and then of those and
then beyond that there were
um
55 of them which were non-suited or
settled before the panel hearing took
60 or so that were settled in a
different way either through a motion
for summary judgment that was ruled on a
mistra mistrial or the case was
withdrawn or there was some other reason
that prop wasn't proper service or
something like that so all of that is
prior to the jury being in panel so the
vast majority thank you other questions
um thanks for taking the question so I
guess my one thought is it seems like
perhaps the the underlying problem here
from what I'm understanding every case
that comes
triggers this process to start creating
this panel
regardless of whether the people
involved may know right from the get-go
that they are not going to want it
um that's correct Okay so
I given the fact that the mechanisms for
doing these are sort of already in place
would it sort of
change the dynamic would there be any
value in your mind of sort of preserving
the ability for someone to go this route
like again we spent the morning talking
about opt-in versus opt out to opt into
this process rather than sort of having
the whole thing get going and then opt
out
um I'm not sure I have a great answer to
that I don't think that the statute as
it currently is written
is a statute that would allow that to
happen obviously but I'm not sure that
you could amend the statute without a
full repeal and then a rewrite because
our system right now is not working
um and I think that you'll hear from a
number of other people that it's
currently not a system that's working so
I hear what you're saying you know would
it make sense to opt in but I think that
that's something would take maybe a
subcommittee to study how that process
would work
um and whether or not it makes sense to
put this the number of resources that we
currently are using and the money that
we're using to do this for an opt-in
which is above my pay grade and
definitely in yours so thank you
other other questions representative
Manos
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
was the purpose of the panels to act as
I think initially that that was part of
the intention I know there's a there's a
gentleman here today that will testify
that was involved in the original
um drafting in the statute I think
originally that there was some hope that
that is what this what um what the
panels would do
that being said I can speak
to my experience which has been that
even though we have this panel process a
number of Judges if not every Superior
Court Judge is also requiring the
litigants to go through alternative
dispute resolution on top of the panel
so
if that was the intent it is not how
it's being being used
representative Horrigan
thank you very much
um
my first question is what is the
compensation for the members of these
panels
so the my understanding is that I I
don't know what a dollar amount and I'm
happy to provide you with that I can get
that for you
um I believe that the person who the the
only member who is compensated and I may
be incorrect and somebody behind me will
probably correct me on this is the
retired judge or
um chairperson on the
um that's on the panel
follow-up thank you and a follow-up if
the panel makes the decision that
displeases some of the litigants are
they ever
threatened with uh being sued or
whatever by the uh unhappy litigants I
think there's a provision in the statute
that says you can't do that right good
that's I'm glad to hear that
other questions
thank you very much okay thank you
good mention I'm sorry if I could just
really briefly open the record again
um that there I believe that there's an
amendment that is going to be offered up
by the hospital Association and although
we support a full repeal of the bill the
superior court is also in agreement with
the amendment um as drafted if that is
all right thank you next I'm going to
call on all uh
man okay that yes from the hospital
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record Paula
minihan Senior vice president state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals in the
state um we are opposed to Senate Bill
65 as amended by the Senate um we were
in favor of the original bill
um that was introduced but we cannot
support 65 which repeals the medical
panel's outright the current medical
panel screening panel statute has been
in place as stated since 2005. we agree
it is time to review the system which
was created to address the costs of the
medical injury reparation system and to
promote availability and affordability
of insurance against liability for
medical injury and I should have put
that in quotes because that's comes from
the original intent prompt appropriate
resolution of medical claims in this
manner that are cost effective for all
parties including the courts is the goal
concerns were were have Arisen in the
past year and I think there's been
reference that we had a meeting
um with the with the judicial branch
with Mr Richard head we agreed it was
time to review the current system and um
we had a I would say a gentleman's
agreement that um that resulted in
Senate Bill 65 but that did get changed
um and so here we are with a bill that
completely repeals it which we do not
support that is um we believe not
appropriate um we don't we believe that
there's time that is needed and that is
what we are asking for consideration and
um so that we can have a thoughtful
discussion with all stakeholders we
don't need a study committee so if we
pause the current panel and repeat delay
the repeal that is something that we
would support because this is too
important um this is um once you appeal
and and some of you that have been here
for a long time now once you repeal a
statute it's very hard to put that back
on the books um so we are just asking
for that consideration
um it does not add any more work for
anyone um if we just pause it and delay
the repeal
um and gives us some time to meet with
stakeholders and look at other options I
my understanding I was not um in this
position I was at the association not in
this position back in 2005 but I
understand that the bill and I'm looking
at representative Smith and
representative Lynn because I know you
were more involved in different roles
but
um this was a compromise my
understanding is that what passed there
are other systems in place Maine is one
system that does a panel before you go
to court so as the judicial branch
representative indicated we're in the we
have dual tracks now and that is
probably not the best system I am
obviously not a lawyer and by but I know
that I have talked with defense
attorneys and I believe
there are some here today and there are
others that couldn't be here because
they're in court but we'll be submitting
testimony they they have worked in other
states there are ways to do this in a
way that again we're just asking for
some time to have a thoughtful
discussion with all stakeholders and
bring forth potentially something and if
if if we don't have a sponsor
um then it will not move forward and the
repeal will happen so I I that I am
respectfully asking for that um
consideration I don't have um I know it
was stated the hospital Association has
a a an amendment I don't um but I have
been working very closely with the
medical society and I know that they
have been working with some of some
members um to for a consideration of an
amendment and we do support that um I
don't know that I can answer any
questions but I'll be happy to try
representative
so it's my understanding that there was
a
Committee in place in order to study
this until 2018
um and it seems like
it had stopped working before that
because if you look there was only one
case that went before the panel in 2017.
so I guess I'm just wondering what do
you think that we're going to gain out
of this that that other committee that
was in place for
almost 20 years couldn't figure out what
was wrong with it what do you think that
we're going to capture and
what would be your expectation there
I'm sorry I don't know of this other
study committee that you speak of um so
I was not part involved in that
um so I'm not I'm not sure and maybe
someone else can discuss that
um
I know that there's a lot of discussion
about the insurance department and and
other data um but it's really looking at
the underlying statute that we need we
now need to consider so
um I don't I think the judicial branch
was indicating you don't just tweak
necessarily tweak the current um
um statute I think again it it just
deserves some attention
um and we were made aware of this intent
to file this bill by by the judicial
branch by Richard head last summer and
that's when we said please before you do
that can we have can we have a
discussion about this because again it
um there are two sides to this and um if
we're if we're our goal is to be more
efficient for all parties including the
three parties I guess um when you
consider the judicial branch it we
haven't had that time to do that um
that's that's all I I'm just I'm sorry I
don't know what study committee you're
referring to
yeah follow-up
so I guess so you you did know about it
since last summer were you able to have
any understanding of what may be the the
possible cause or the problem with the
committee and I guess a secondary
question would also be when this panel
was working how much was it saving was
were there less cases that you feel were
ending up being filed and
was it resulting in
less payments for it I I am not able to
answer that question
um and as far as when we were made aware
that's when we we asked for a study
committee because the initial
proposal was to just put in a repeal
bill and we asked for a study committee
so that we could look at other options
again there are other options across the
the country and we we just do not
believe outright repeal is the answer at
this time
representative Smith
thank you
said this is too important
uh to have a repeal
and yet the numbers that have been
presented to us
would not indicate
that
this process was considered important by
any of the sides involved because the
numbers are so low
and again I will defer to experts behind
me but because I'm not involved in these
but it's because they the Dual tracks
and it is determined at a certain point
that it makes more sense to just settle
um because again I think the Dual track
makes it very unique
um because there you're spending a lot
of time doing both so they I and again I
I will stop there and ask
experts behind me to to address that
thank you thank you it's a very it's a
fair very fair question and I don't
think anyone wants to put you on on the
spot so it might just be that you you
know you move aside and let other people
deal with it that's fair representative
representative
so you had stated that you were
representing the 26 hospitals in the
state and I just have a question related
to that do you know if the hospitals
would be on board with I know one of the
biggest issues with getting these panels
was actually getting a physician to
participate in them are the hospitals on
board with
putting something in the physician's
contracts that they have to participate
in like say one of these panels every
certain number of years
um I I would not I don't have the
authority to to state that at this time
that but I think that is
um if that is one of the problems I do
understand
um that the current system involved
working
um with um
reaching out to doctors through the
medical society but certainly we could
help in that regard as well because
obviously you need you need experts to
be on the panel so that that certainly
is would be a fair consideration
representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair
um it seems to me you're just asking for
time and because this bill is in the
possession of the Judiciary Committee
would the summer be enough time for you
to have conversations with stakeholders
or do you believe there needs to be more
time and what would more time get you
um we have we can act on this bill up
until November 1st so sure
um well the we were hoping for a two to
three year pause and then delay of
repeal I believe we were looking at 2026
um so um because everyone's very busy
and um and I think that there needs to
be some thoughtful discussions and
bringing folks together and when you
when you bring stakeholders together
that is um that's a time time consuming
process and to do it fairly I would say
we'd need some time and to get through
another idea was to get into the next
budget cycle if if there are changes
that needed to be made and
Appropriations needed to be considered
so that would I don't I don't believe
um the summer time would be enough time
thank you for taking my question uh it
appears to me you're talking two or
three years to come up with something
we're settling so few of these
that if we lose two or three years of
case settlements to this to this method
they really won't make much difference
so we could just get rid of the of the
legislation you could have whatever
meetings you want to put together a more
reasonable method
uh and uh you know and then you'd have
what you wanted I mean I don't
understand why just suspending it or
holding it or trying something like that
um in my experience of um
I'm having trouble seeing you um in my
experience unfortunately once you repeal
a statute it is really really difficult
to get it back
um so that is the reason we and I don't
honestly I don't see quite the a
difference of just pot we're pausing the
process and delaying the repeal
um I guess I could um this is this is
all I mean I'm never in front of this
committee but I'm in front of HHS a lot
um and a good example that we went
through
um and worked with rep with
representative Neil Kirk was the repeal
of the con a certificate of need we had
a five-year repeal date in that Pro in
that that gave us
um we knew it was going to happen but it
gave us time to create a a different
system and it's called the special
healthcare service um system that um
license that Senator Bradley worked with
us and it is
um something that is is thoughtful
um and and protects the patients it is
um it's look it's trying to save money
and it is not certificate of need
because we knew that was going away but
it gave us the time to get something on
in place in in place of certificate of
need
um so that is that's and I guess my only
example or analogy that um and I worked
very very hard on that bill and I I am
we're very proud of that law so
um that's an example of
um working with the legislature and just
in the meantime I guess I just it is
delaying the repeal but it's um I don't
see it's not like the process would
continue it's still being paused
what other so I guess I I guess I have a
question I mean isn't that a significant
distinction
because correct me if I'm wrong but
during this five-year window of the
certificate of need process
being replaced coming to an end and
being replaced
during that five-year period the
certificate of need remained in effect
yes that's right but what you're talking
about here is if we accept what I think
you're proposing we would suspend
immediately the screening panel process
and with the possibility that it might
come back in three years and so I guess
I'm you know what
and I please understand I don't direct
this at you in any way personally but I
what
this really smacks of to me is
if if you're willing to have this be
suspended for three years you're sort of
admitting it doesn't really do anything
we don't really need if we don't have
this in effect for the next three years
the sky isn't going to fall in and so if
that's true
um then that seems to me a significant
difference from the from the certificate
of need example and it frankly it's sort
of it it kind of I have to say honestly
it smacks to me of like let's just see
if we can you know if we can just hang
on to a thread maybe there'll be some
way in three years that we'll be able to
get this resurrected whereas as
representative testerman was pointing
out why if this you know if it if we
repeal this
and and and somehow on the unexpected to
all of us the sky falls in which I don't
from all we've seen in the in the over
the last 20 years I don't think that's
going to happen but if the sky did fall
in we can reenact the law
you know we could just take it off take
519 off the shelf I suppose and reenact
it
I think the difference is we're not
asking to just reinstate the the panels
as they exist we're looking for time as
the again this was never our idea this
was um presented by the judicial panel
and they wanted to repeal it because it
wasn't working
um but remember we were coming out of a
three-year
um horrible
um pandemic and the hospitals were at
the front lines of that so we were well
aware of that um and to just say let's
repeal it it's like wait a minute you
don't want to do anything after three
years of a pandemic without thinking
this through we we tried and we
suggested the medical community
um that we have a study committee
because we did not agree that just
repealing outright because again there
are other
options out there and so
maybe not everyone agrees that we should
have another option we prefer that
opportunity to consider another option
that's all we're saying well I'm not
saying we're going to just put back in
um what the the panels that we have
today because like you said I don't
think they're working
um and there are reasons again the Dual
track is one reason that they may not be
working that's all all right other
questions for this witness uh yes
representative Smith then representative
Perez and representative Morgan
thank you
um
what if we were
to itl the Senate bill
and
keep things
as they are
um would that mean we would be would we
therefore be eliminating any
encouragement
that all the parties
might need in order to look at how that
system works and see if there's a way to
improve it
that's another approach to if everyone
believes that it's not working to sit
down and and try to work something out
I think I'm I think I'm answering your
question
did you say it would not encourage
because I think it would encourage don't
you well I don't know because it's been
here for quite a while right there have
been almost no the numbers that are
involved are very very low they would
not indicate
that this is something that makes sense
um
that being the case we could just go
ahead with the Senate proposal and
repeal period
we can say put it on hold
if we had any reason to believe that by
putting it on hold that the interested
parties would in fact do something about
trying to
improve it
or we could do something more drastic I
mean for example
the one particular example is that Maine
requires the panels right and so it
might just be okay let's just dabble a
little bit and require the panels and
the bill is here because rather than in
Health and Human Services or another
committee because of the role of the
judicial branch plays in this
um
uh
it's very hard to see what in fact we as
a legislature should do that would make
these independent parties
um step up to the plate
well I for one
um can speak for the hospital
Association that we are interested in
actually
having stakeholders come together and
whether we have a study committee a
legislative study committee or not and I
think that's why we're saying if you
pause it we we're committed to trying to
look at Alternatives
um I don't I we didn't have the time to
do that when we became aware of the of
Senate Bill 65 being introduced to
um and well the original plan excuse me
not 65 as introduced because that was a
study committee because that was after
we did Richard head did bring us
together and um we we did and the
medical society did ask for it for it to
be studied so that's how I think 65 came
to be not all the stakeholders that were
in that room um are in the zoom room I
should say
um apparently agreed with that um so
that's why that's why you have the bill
before you
representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
if you wait
if you keep this the way it is or freeze
it or whatever you want to do and then
you come back
in three years is that what you're you
have to start all over again you you
have to start all you're going to have
another perhaps another huge different
group
um I I personally am not for putting
Band-Aids on something I personally
think it makes more sense to start fresh
with something and say we had a we had a
um
statute that didn't work and this is why
it didn't work
rather than band-aiding it it just I've
worked in the healthcare field for 42
years as an intensive care nurse I get
it I know it's very difficult the thing
I saw immediately with this wrong is
that you had two paths going at the same
time I agree with you two pass at the
same time that's ridiculous right and um
but I wasn't here when that came out
yeah
um
so you know I just think fresh to me I
don't understand why and I know you say
it's because you see if something goes
away but you're gonna put together
something that's entirely different
you're looking to put together maybe a
mediation prior to and
um this hasn't this wasn't working prior
to 217. so my question is
I'd like to see you give us some credit
that we could bring it back perhaps and
you know different people different
different outcomes so
um I guess my question is would you
consider it this going away starting
fresh
I completely respect what you're saying
and of and I understand your perspective
um again there I think you're right
fundamentally the problem with the
current system is it's a dual track
there are other systems like Maine and I
think representative Smith identified
that and others that is an example of a
system that really does work and there
are lawyers in New Hampshire that work
in both States and have said to me
outright the main system does work
um so by that's why we were supportive
of 70 of 65 as introduced it was a study
committee and that would have given us
an opportunity to say this is the
current system and the force it does
force people to the table
um and that that is the good part of
passing a study committee or a
commission I know I know it's a lot of
work on for everyone but it forces
people at the table to actually
that understand the system to consider
alternatives and to bring ideas
um again if we
we were just trying to we're not you
could go back to 65 as introduced but we
weren't we were saying
um why don't we just pause and then
possibly just delay the repeal so it's
it's kind of a it's another alternative
that's all but uh it the as you stated
the bills in your committee it is up to
you our position is that we would like
an opportunity to try to look at
Alternatives and again from my
experience once you lose once a statute
is is repealed it is very difficult to
come back that's all
follow-up yes so you would be bringing
forward
so you would not be Bandit band-aiding
this one you would be bringing home it
appears to from what you're saying you
could possibly be bringing the main Bill
to New Hampshire it's it's still a um
screening panel it's a it's a type of so
I don't I have not looked at the statute
to say what we would change in the
statute again this was um this was not
suggested by us um so we are just
responding to a bill that was into that
was presented by the judicial or an idea
by the judicial branch and now what um
we did not support the bill when it was
repealed in the Senate um so now we are
this is our position I I know that
you're running out of time and I know
there are others that want to speak
representative Oregon yes it seems like
what you're asking us to do is something
along the lines of an amended version of
the original Senate bill which has said
section I didn't look at it until just
now while I was sitting here but appears
section one was a study committee
section two was a
suspensions would be no new claims but
very but the exist three existing panels
would still be able to continue their
work and then
um followed in the future by the repeal
of the whole statute and that one was
2024 you seem to think something more
like 2026 is more appropriate so am I
like interpreting your testimony right
and yes yes so that's that that's what
basically you're asking us to do is
revive the original Senate version of
the bill but without a study without a
formal study committee I guess you could
say yes thanks all right other questions
representative
yeah maybe just following up on that um
thanks for taking the question
um
I guess I'll frame it by saying you know
we have heard about the strains on the
court system multiple times in multiple
ways we've heard about
um a number of other extra you know I
don't know what the word is not judicial
but extra court system processes in
other areas you know and most people
have said those were working very well
and people took advantage of those
um
am I writing in that
essentially Mr head's reason for for
proposing this in the first place was
essentially to take the burden off of
them in the short term
um not necessarily to be opposed to the
concept but to be opposed to the the
resource utilization and and and did I
understand you saying that there was
original the original agreement sort of
not not in this in the statute but was
but was around basically
taking time to to revise this or see if
and the idea behind your I guess
constant's conceptual Amendment would be
that if nothing happens within three
years the bill would still repeal
correct the bill would still repeal in
three years I I hesitate
um representative to
um to put to speak for Richard head um
and I he's not here
um but we do um we have talked with with
him
um and um I I don't I think he could he
understands our position
um he knows that we do not support the
repeal
um I don't believe
um he and I think the judicial branch
representative
um testified that he understood and I
think he could I believe could but I
could live with our idea but I don't I
don't want to actually um even say that
so when the bill was initially
introduced it was only to have a member
of the Senate and then three members of
is anybody or any
body from the hospital Association or
anybody gonna team up on trying to come
up with a resolution or is the
expectation just that the general court
figure out a solution well the way study
committees typically work
um representative is that the interested
parties certainly participate in that
it's just a difference between a
commission and a committee a study
committee and a commission but yes of
course we would participate
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much thank you but
next I'm going to call on Dave gottisman
I thank you uh I'm David goddessman uh
I'm an attorney in Nashua
I'm a member of the New Hampshire
Association for justice I also was in
the Senate when this legislation was
passed in 2005 over my objection at that
time
I'm going to have Kevin introduce
himself and then we'll give you some
comments Uh Kevin Dugan I'm an attorney
in Manchester
um
here both personally as someone who
practices in this field and has for many
years and also on the behalf of the New
Hampshire Association for justice and I
have to confess uh Mr chairman I'm very
uncomfortable not standing to address
I think before uh I get into my comments
there are a couple things that I think
maybe the committee is not aware of in
how this process works there was a
comment about uh
the panel being assembled I just want to
explain that once
the retired judge assembles a lawyer
and a doctor
and a panel is actually convened if it
if it actually takes place
and both parties have to pay for expert
witnesses to participate in that
proceeding as if it were a trial
the finding
can be
three to three to zero
two to one in favor
one to two in favor which means it's
against or three to zero
that there is no malpractice
so
what happens with that finding if it is
three to zero under any circumstances
either for or against that can be
admitted
to a jury trial
in front of a jury it is not binding on
them it is just additional information
that a preliminary hearing happened with
a panel and that's explained by the
court and that that is before them and
that the jury can make their own
decision about how this case should come
out could come out regardless of what
the panel said
so in many cases where it's two to one
people have spent an inordinate amount
of money
and it is all for naught because it is
if it never happened
so in the rare cases that it's 3-0 then
the question of how it's handled at
trial comes before the court
uh
representative uh Oregon I think is are
you I representative or again yeah
I think uh asked uh who can wave the
panel uh how many people it takes both
attorneys to waive the panel one
attorney cannot wave the panel on their
own
so uh one of the things that happens is
as these cases are proceeding one a
panel proceeding and one a regular Court
proceeding
time is being spent on both money is
being spent by both sides
and the court has assigned a retired
judge to assemble a panel which
sometimes has conflicts which sometimes
has uh
their own cases to handle and when I say
conflicts I mean conflicts of interest
because they know the lawyer they know
the doctor and then it becomes a matter
of when can we schedule this and then
there are those conflicts and those are
the realities of what's happening with
this system
uh
one of the things that has not really
been focused on is at the time that this
happened at the time of this legislation
it first came before the legislature in
2004 and it died in a committee of
conference
and then in 2005 the new bill came up
and it passed
but at the time if I recall correctly
mediation was not a requirement in our
legal system mediation is when the
parties to a lawsuit are forced to get
together and try to resolve the case
an answer to representative uh
pay Perez uh question this is the
opportunity that people need to try to
resolve the case
uh I think of all the cases that get
filed
ninety percent of them go away through
the court system they don't go to trial
they either end up getting resolved or
they get dismissed so we're talking
about uh whether or not the the system
as we know it which is a system that is
run by a jury
in every single case
do we have confidence in the jury system
we do and we feel that the jury system
is working
so uh
in this legislation
uh as
has been brought out
the insurance department was supposed to
be reviewing this every
so often and reporting to the
legislature and the legislature was
supposed to read these reports and the
legislature was supposed to take action
once the reports were given but what has
really happened is nothing uh the
insurance department has as of January
of
2023 and you have that report that was
just submitted by uh Senator bird so
uh says this is not working
and this is something that should be
done away with
so the fear is I just want to talk about
what the fears were at the time what we
heard
we heard that it could be done in a
timely manner it was promised that these
panels would take no longer than six
months at the outside to be completed
it won't cost too much for the people
who are injured
and it'll change premiums
and you can weed out frivolous cases
and you can keep doctors from leaving
the state
because there was some fear that because
of malpractice premiums they were being
forced to leave the state
well what have we found
it takes too long
the Lays are lasting for more than a
year with the panel while the case is
proceeding
the panels are difficult to assemble as
I said due to conflicts of interest and
scheduling conflicts
it's not changed the ultimate outcome
side
it hasn't reduced the premiums
it has nothing to do effectively with
weeding out frivolous cases and I and I
will say
medical malpractice cases are the
hardest cases to bring before court they
are defended uh
fully and no stone is left unturned by
the the the defense in these cases so uh
no lawyer who knows what they're doing
is going to bring these cases unless
they they can project that it is
worthwhile in bringing them
the experts in these cases are
extraordinarily expensive
so if you have to have a panel you have
to have an expert who testifies in some
fashion at the panel so you're you're
costing both sides double the expense in
terms of handling the case
uh the reports that you have before you
show that the loss adjustment expenses
which is legal fees are up for defense
and that Indemnity money and settlements
paid to the injured parties is less
and is being waived as you can see from
the statistics that have been presented
to you almost all the time why is it
being waived the attorneys on the
defense do not have the power to waive
the the uh panel on their own they have
to ask their companies they are
insurance companies who make a business
decision as to whether or not it is
worth proceeding with a panel and a jury
trial they have to evaluate the case and
they do so and they're trying to save
money and they do by saying the case is
waived and we don't have to go to a
panel
one thing that I just want to address
um is that that we we heard this
suggestion
about two or three years someone handed
me a draft for
an amendment to Senate Bill 65 which
says that basically this
law should be suspended as of January
1st 2023 which is you know behind us
and that uh
no action for medical injury shall be
assigned to a screening panel
and then three years from now
the law will disappear
now
um
any of you who are in business
know if you have a business problem
know if the money's not coming in or
things aren't going well you have to
make decisions today
you don't make a decision today
that three years from now I'm going to
end this problem
this problem is something that was
brought forward not by the Association
for justice but by the court system
asking you to consider the fact that
this is not working
when this meeting that was talked about
was held between Richard head and the
um
the original plan was a complete repeal
the compromise was that it would come in
and they would have a study committee to
do exactly what this last speaker said
to see if they can come up with
something
uh one of the plans that was suggested
was this main plant and unfortunately
the attorney who testified at the Senate
hearing Ben Gideon who was a malpractice
lawyer from Maine was not able to come
today but he told the the senate
committee how terrible the system over
there is I urge you to read his
testimony which we will have a copy sent
to the committee
so that you will see what he had to say
uh
I I don't think putting this out for
years makes any sense as the as as the
chairman indicated that this is just
pushing it down the road
and uh
I'll let Kevin say his two cents and
thank you judge Glenn I only have about
two cents so I won't be too long
um but before I
say anything I just want to point out
something that really hasn't been
emphasized and that is that the
overwhelming majority of malpractice
cases get settled
today and have for many years without a
trial and without a panel hearing and
that's why we don't use them because
going through the panel system creates a
delay and expense that we don't need to
settle cases
Dave God has been mentioned that 90 plus
of malpractice cases get resolved I
would say it's even substantially higher
than that probably 95 percent and all
that happens without a trial or a panel
hearing uh thanks in large part to a
Court rule that requires that all cases
go to mediation at some point and when
any case is filed one of the first
things as Judge Lynn knows that happens
is that the parties with the court
develop a schedule for everything to
occur starting with a trial date and
then working backwards and one of the
dates is a deadline by which you have to
participate in alternative dispute
resolution
the commonly known as mediations and
that's where the vast majority of these
cases get resolved so the end of the
story is that's why no one's using this
panel system is that cases are getting
resolved without the expense and delay
of going through a panel hearing which
invariably use tens of thousands of
dollars for both sides which just makes
getting cases settled harder so
having done the end first
um I have a long history with the whole
panel process here having been on the
very original study committee that spent
many many many hours in this room 20
years ago
and we listened to many many hours of
testimony from insurance company
actuaries about how they set insurance
rates which you can't imagine how
painful that was Dr Gary Woods who was
behind me in the back row also served on
that commission 20 years ago and as well
aware of how how much time was spent
talking about
panel systems including the main system
so
the majority recommendation of that
commission was to adopt the main style
panel screening system
the minority authored a report which I
brought copies of and I was going
through my files the other day in
anticipation of this these files are 20
years old
and and this is part of the Minority
Report on that Commission
Maine's mandatory pre-litigation
screening Panel System went into effect
in 1987.
Ten Years Later the main Bureau of
insurance commissioned an independent
analysis of the effectiveness of the
panel system
by Ami risk Consultants they found that
the average time between notice
and the panel decision was 1.7 years
the study concluded that the net effect
of the panel system was an increased
cost to insurers
that was sounded very familiar to me
when I read it and when I turned the
page I realized this because I wrote
that Minority Report 20 years ago
but that's been our experience after all
these years too that the panel system
that we adopted although it differed
somewhat from the main system
Judge Lynn reported to the legislature
some years ago on the number of cases
filed and the number of cases going
through the system and
um
it took about one and a half years to
get a panel hearing these days you can
get a trial within one and a half years
and as I say most cases settle without a
trial or a panel hearing so
the need for it just isn't there
one other point is that I think it's
why the whole Panel System the impetus
behind the panel system and the first
line of chapter 519 which was the
screening panel bill
says it all availability and
affordability of insurance against
liability for medical injury is
essential
this chapter affirms the intent of the
general court to promote availability
and affordability of insurance against
viability for medical injury claims for
medical injury should be resolved as
early and inexpensively as possible
so at the time we were having a
malpractice insurance crisis as was
where most of the states which has
happened periodically over the years
that is not an issue anymore you haven't
heard anyone complaining about the
availability or affordability of medical
malpractice insurance in many years so
even if the panel system we're working
which it's not the original problem that
it was supposed to address
evaporated many years ago
we think it makes sense to repeal it
because it wastes Court resources
the overwhelming number of cases settle
without a panel hearing the impetus
behind the panel hearing system has been
resolved by both Market forces and other
changes and to that point
um I
thought it was interesting an article in
um
address the causes of
insurance rates going down in part and
they said that well they commented that
the National Practitioner Data Bank as a
National Organization to which every
medical malpractice insurance payment
has to be reported and the hospitals and
medical societies have access to that
and that data reveals a remarkable
phenomenon the number of paid claims
against Physicians has decreased by 75
percent in the past 20 years
reasons for the precipitous decline are
unclear
whatever the cause the sharp decrease in
medical malpractice litigation has
probably helped avert the kinds of
instabilities that roiled medical
liability insurance markets in the
mid-1970s the mid-1980s and the early
2000s the last of which is what um gave
rise to the panel system here so in
short
it's not working
people don't use it and it makes sense
to take it off the books and happen to
take any questions questions for these
Witnesses
yes representative Manos
s where you have a retired judge or
somebody with judicial experience or
um and a physician as composed as
compared to mediation
where you may be having a mediator who's
um
I've appeared before panels as a party
and I've actually sat on panels as well
as the lawyer member
um
and in my experience they were very
deliberate in considering the evidence
and coming to a conclusion
um
so it's not that part of the process
process that we had any issue with it's
just that it's an expensive process that
we don't need because most people have
great success with good mediators and
you know mediation is a voluntary
process
and quite a bit of time is spent on the
two sides agreeing on a mediator because
not Everyone likes the same mediator and
you know we always wind up with someone
all parties can agree with and because
it's a voluntary process
with an agreed upon mediator I think
that mediator has a lot more credibility
because everyone's agreed on him and
there are
good mediators in New Hampshire that do
it full-time they're well known to the
bar and they do a really really good job
other questions for this Witness
are these Witnesses I should say um so
you know can I just ask you one or both
of you can you can you just explain for
the members of the of the committee here
in the under the main system
is it I understand that it's you you do
the panel before you bring suit but can
if is there is there an opportunity
under that system to waive them in there
was it both the lawyer if the lawyers on
both sides say we don't want to do the
panel can they still bring suit
I know you're did you want to answer
that I'm sorry I know years ago you
could wave it I've had one main case and
they waived it so I don't know what the
current practice is
um but with respect to
um
the order of the process in Maine you
have to go through the panel process
before you can even file a lawsuit and
that was very thoroughly discussed in
this room that summer of 2003 that we'll
all remember and was uh considered and
not included in the New Hampshire bill
because it ran contrary to a Supreme
Court case called Carson versus malware
which threw out a statutory requirement
to give priesthood notice and
malpractice cases and it was a unanimous
unanimous decision that's been followed
for the many years since so that order
of business as they do it in Maine was
specifically not adopted in New
Hampshire because the thought was that
would not survive constitutional
challenge
right so I mean it strikes me though
even if I mean even if you put that case
aside if if it's
if under the main system
you can't both parties can agree to
waive it and then go to truck go and go
to court
I guess you know to the extent it's been
suggested we should adopt the main
system even if we could what's the why
is there any reason to believe that
would make a difference I mean if why
why wouldn't they waive it to the same
extent they're waving it now just
because it's before suit so what
I don't I mean I don't understand that
maybe somebody else that's going to
testify against us can explain that but
I don't quite see why that would make a
difference I don't think it would I
think the same result would obtain here
and people who have experience with the
panel system
wave it because it's it's not working
for either side
all right other questions
thank you both very much
next I'm going to call on Kimberly
Kirkland
foreign
thank you Mr chair I too have a hard
time not feeling like I should stand up
um and thank you for hearing my
testimony my name is Kimberly Kirkland
I'm a lawyer in Manchester I'm also the
president-elect of the New Hampshire
Association for justice but more
pertinent I think to what I'm going to
testify to here today is that from 2000
to 2014 I was on the faculty of what was
then Franklin Pierce Law Center now UNH
Franklin Pierce school of law where I
taught legal ethics and civil procedure
and as a tenured member of The Faculty
at the law school one of my
responsibilities was scholarship and I
did empirical scholarship on the legal
profession
so in looking at this issue I've tried
to do that with the empirical scholar
hat on and have dug into some of the
data about the screening panels which
may answer some of the questions that
have been
um
posed so I what I'd like to do thinking
that this is helpful to you would be to
just run through some of the statistics
from the insurance department that were
gathered uh over the course of the life
of panels from
2007 through
2020 or 18 was the last day that the
insurance department was actually
collecting data on how these panels were
working and how it was impacting the
resolution of cases as people have said
before the intent was to reduce
malpractice insurance premiums to weed
out frivolous claims to reduce defense
costs and to review reduce the time to
resolution
for a medical malpractice cases but the
insurance department data for for
instance 2000 in 12 to 2018
indicates that if you look at cases
where screening panels were waived so
they weren't
initiated
93.4 percent of the cases settled
pre-trial in cases or situations where
the screening panel was in fact
initiated
91.8 percent settled pre-trial so you
had a higher rate of settlements when
there was no screening panel initiated
um
according to
the insurance department data the
screening panels also slowed down
resolution of the cases as some folks
have already mentioned in 2018 over all
types of cases the insurance department
data suggested that for the last six
years
the uh
time to resolution increased if you had
a screening panel to 28 months whereas
if no screening panel was initiated it
only took 24 months to resolve a medical
malpractice case uh medical malpractice
screening panels also increase the cost
of resolution of these cases so in cases
where the screening panels were waived
24.5 percent of the money spent by the
defense on these cases
was attributable to or excuse me was
attributable to Legal costs so the cost
of paying lawyers experts the litigation
costs where screening panels were
initiated 35 of the total amounts paid
by insurance companies for medical
malpractice cases was attributed able to
Legal costs so the amount of money going
to lawyers and experts increased from 24
to 35 percent in cases that went through
a screening panel so it ends up being
more expensive for the insurers
um and a higher percentage of the Money
Paid is actually paid to defense lawyers
and experts and in general costs than
gets paid in Indemnity payments to the
actual patients who were injured there's
also been some conversation about
medical malpractice screening processes
in other states
the information that I have is that
there are a total of uh 25 states where
there is some screening panel process on
the books but in 16 States like in New
Hampshire those panels aren't really
being used
so across the country the trend has been
to initiate this panel system in the
hopes that it would reduce costs reduce
time to resolution weed out frivolous
claims people are finding it's not
working and then
um they're just staying on the books but
not really being used the cases are
being or the screening panels are being
waived and in 2017 Kentucky actually
repealed or actually there was a ruling
that the screening panels were processed
was unconstitutional and Massachusetts
in 2017 rescinded its screening panel
process it left it on the books and said
either side could unilaterally opt out
which you know is essentially uh what
we're doing right now
so in some I would just say I think the
real problem with the panels is they're
not working and as those who come before
me have said it's in my experience now
back in practice doing plaintiff's
medical malpractice work I go into every
single case saying we the plaintiff will
wave the panel and so it's always up to
the defense lawyer whether they want to
waive or not I've been practicing doing
plaintiff's medical malpractice work
exclusively since 2014 and I have not
had one screening panel they've been
waived in every single case and I can
only imagine that the reason for that is
that the insurance companies have found
that they increase costs they increase
time to resolution and that we the
plaintiff's lawyers actually do the work
of weeding out frivolous cases because
we pay for experts and the costs of
litigation
in these cases and we don't take them on
unless we feel very confident that we
have a meritorious case that will end up
in a settlement for our clients
otherwise we lose our shirts so we end
up being the screen for frivolous cases
I'm happy to take questions questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next I'm going to call on Holly
Haynes
thank you chief justice Lynn and
chairman Lynn
um I too feel like I should be standing
in front of you
thank you members of the committee for
allowing me to speak today I'm here in
support of repealing the medical
malpractice screening panel law my name
is Holly Haines I'm an attorney at
Abramson Brown and Dugan in Manchester
New Hampshire and I practice exclusively
medical malpractice on behalf of injured
patients I've been doing this work for
20 years and I can tell you I've been
working on studying these medical
malpractice screening panels since I
started at this office one of my first
assignments was to collect data and
review data from Maine for Kevin Dugan
my partner who spoke earlier who was on
the study Commission
um I also wrote an article with Kevin
Dugan which I believe has been submitted
to you we wrote that article in 2007
anticipating expressing our concerns and
predicting what may happen with the
panel system in New Hampshire and
analyzing the Massachusetts and main
panel systems and the Constitutional
concerns I will that should be
considered my written testimony for this
hearing and I will tell you that
everything that we predicted in 2007 has
been born out and it is laid out in that
article in detail
before I went into this field I did work
for the judicial branch as a law clerk
for the superior court and for the
Supreme Court I'm also a past president
for the New Hampshire Association for
justice
and as you've heard from many people
already today from the legal Community
from the insurance department and the
judicial branch the
screening panels just aren't working
um I think every interested party gave
this a really good effort in the first
several years that the panels were
enacted I served as a screening panel
member several times in the first five
years they were in effect I tried cases
to screening panels in the first five
years they were in effect and I have
been appointed as a screening panel
member in recent years but after doing
all of the work the panels were waived
before they ever went to a hearing so I
can attest to the amount of work that
goes into these panels both trying them
and as a panel member and
as you can see from the statistics
provided by the judicial branch
there were numerous panels in the first
five years in 2010 they precipitously
dropped um
and it's because after giving it a good
faith effort everyone realized that they
just don't work they cost more and they
take more time than trying a case or
moving forward with mandatory ADR in the
court system
it was the court system who initially
brought this legislation because of the
administrative burdens that it imposes
on them and they've been clear that it
does not work or it has not been working
the insurance department has confirmed
that the panel statute has not
achieved any of its intended purposes
the legal Community from the defense bar
I know there's at least one defense
attorney here but there were no I
thought it was noticeable absence at the
Senate hearing that no defense attorneys
spoke in opposition to this bill and
there's limited attendance today in
opposition to it and
the defense attorneys who defend these
cases are excellent lawyers very well
prepared but they know the costs that go
into preparing these cases and they know
the expense and they work on behalf of
their clients the insurance companies
who are the ones who have to pay those
costs and I suspect that that is one of
the reasons they may not be here in
droves
I was asked to come here today to talk
about the Practical experience of the
panels and just why there are
already screening mechanisms in place
not just the mandatory ADR in the court
system but why our system itself screens
out frivolous claims and there are not
the screening panel is supposed to
screen out those claims
um
the reasons that this has not worked
first and foremost the way the statute
was written it could never be
implemented and it hasn't been
implemented as written because panels
can't happen in the six months
anticipated by the statute or even in
the 11 months that's allowed by the
statute it usually takes about a year
and a half
um
the numbers of cases have not
substantially dropped since screening
panels were enacted the panels aren't
being used and
Ben Gideon an attorney from Maine who
spoke at the Senate hearing explained
that Maine's experience has been
identical in Maine in fact it takes a
year and a half to get through the panel
process and it's prerequisite to filing
suit so sue gets delayed by a year and a
half they can't even start their jury
trial process while we have a parallel
claim intentionally so it doesn't delay
the right to trial by jury which is a
right guaranteed by our Constitution
that was one of the major issues studied
so the original question of why there
aren't more screening panels being heard
in New Hampshire and why we have
inherent screening mechanisms in our
system versus plaintiff's lawyers work
on a contingency fee basis that means we
don't get paid unless we are successful
in bringing a case for our clients
we bear the costs of all of those claims
and to bring a case to trial it often
costs it is always tens of thousands of
dollars sometimes it is more than a
hundred thousand dollars just an expert
witness costs and expenses to take a
case to trial we don't bear those costs
frivolously we aren't going to incur
those costs in a case that we don't
think is going to be successful that in
itself is the first mechanism that
screens out frivolous cases and I
believe at the original testimony in
2005 when the statute was enacted Marty
honigberg who represented the Medical
Society at the time as their lobbyist
and is now a superior court judge
testified that there are no frivolous
claims in New Hampshire
the second is that we're required by
Statute to support our medical
malpractice cases with expert testimony
we cannot file suit in good faith
without having a board-certified medical
expert who will support each element of
our claim those medical experts as you
heard from others
now some of the experts in the Harvard
system and Johns Hopkins system are
charging a thousand dollars an hour to
review medical records and to testify it
is very expensive to get a medical
expert to review your case and that
again is another screening mechanism
that prevents people from bringing
frivolous claims
third if we bring a case a frivolous
case and we take it to trial and we lose
we are subject to paying the defense
costs for that trial we've incurred a
hundred thousand dollars for going to
trial the defense probably has less
because they don't have the burden of
proof but we may have to pay their 25 or
50 000 in addition because we're subject
to that that in itself is another
screening mechanism inherent in the
system that prevents plaintiff's lawyers
from bringing frivolous claims
and finally New Hampshire is a very very
small state it's a small bar judges know
you as chief justice Lynn can attest
defense lawyers know you plaintiff's
lawyers know the defense lawyers we work
together it's such a small bar bringing
these cases we have to work together
every day and you lose credibility and
you lose the trust of your colleagues if
you're bringing frivolous claims and
that's just something I don't think any
of us would ever compromise our
professional ethics by bringing a
frivolous claim or our personal
the fifth is
reason or inherent screening mechanism
is the jury trial everyone in New
Hampshire has a right to a trial by jury
and
if a frivolous case somehow slips
through the cracks a jury is going to
see that and they're going to rule in
the defense favor our jury system works
I think anyone who has ever served on a
jury will tell you what works and
um jurors consider these cases very
carefully and no one would bring a
frivolous claim
all of these built-in screening
mechanisms work
and we don't need a screening panel and
we don't need further study to address
this
um
just a few facts from my own experiences
I have not had a case go to a screening
panel since 2010 so it's been more than
13 years
before that all of the cases that went
to panel from our office were either
three to O panel findings in our favor
or two to one panel findings in our
favor and the one was always the medical
member of the panel who often has a very
hard time finding against a colleague in
their profession it's a doctor that they
work with professionally
never once has the prospect or the
occurrence of a screening panel
dissuaded us from bringing a case or
made me second guess bringing a case
never once has the prospect or
occurrence of a screening panel ever
made me second guess the confidence that
I have in my cases
and
never once have I had in my career a
defense attorney say that there are
frivolous cases being filed in New
Hampshire these are the people we work
with every day and I just wanted to
address a couple of the points that have
been raised by Representatives already I
believe it was um representative tur who
asked if there it would be better if
there was a voluntary screening panel as
opposed to mandatory that imposes the
administrative burdens on the courts
I'd like to remind the committee that in
2005 when this panel was this statute
was enacted
the legislature repealed RSA 519a which
was a voluntary screening panel process
for all professional negligence claims
that's what it was that existed it was
existing in the law it was repealed to
make a mandatory process that now we
know doesn't work so that was there it's
been tried and it was the proponents of
this legislation who eliminated the
voluntary process
um
a second thing that I believe my partner
already addressed is the mandatory ADR
it is mandatory in the court you cannot
avoid going to either arbitration or
mediation you cannot go to trial without
attending ADR and giving a report to the
court and the judges will get on you if
you haven't done it in a timely manner
or by the deadline
and finally I believe
um representative Smith you asked what
would happen if if this were just itl'd
and allowed to continue as things are
that's not going to do anything to
relieve the administrative burdens on
the court system when this was passed
and this is addressed in the article
that I submitted there was never a
fiscal note no one ever gave the
judicial branch additional funding to
have these panels they devote one full
Personnel to this whose
I'm sure whose Services could be better
served doing other
jobs for the Superior Court they also
have to devote in addition to having a
retired judge or person with judicial
experience they have to devote a
courtroom a court security officer a
court reporter
electricity hearing I mean all of these
things that are also administrative
burdens they have to reserve all of that
in the judicial branch that was never
accounted for when this came in so it
yelling this is going to leave the
mandatory process in place that Court
Personnel is going to have to continue
working to and panel these panels that
don't happen and try to find piano
members I believe at the um
Senate hearing the Richard head
testified that often Angela Pearl the
Superior Court panel coordinator is
stuck Googling Physicians to try to find
people in the Specialties because they
don't have anyone who's voluntarily
going to do it she is spending her days
making phone calls trying to get panel
members to serve on panels that are then
waived and never happen that just can't
be a good use of her time
for our judicial branch and it's not a
good use of any of the panel members
time who get appointed and then the
panel hearing is waived and with that
thank you for listening and I'll take
any questions questions for this witness
yes representative Horrigan thank you
very much both attorney Kirkland and we
also had a memo that DJ Bettencourt the
Deputy Commissioner Insurance
um submitted to Senator Bradley back in
the Senate process and they both
agreed
um his number he they both agree that
the average is 28 months for uh well
let's see exactly what 28 28 months for
uh one with the screening and 24 for one
where there is no screening panel but
what's obviously an average means 50 in
averages and average what's the what are
the lower and upper limits for how long
these two processes take
I'm not sure if I can answer that I
think someone from the judicial branch
would need to I can tell you my personal
experience from our office
um when panel hearings were held the
panels were never held in under a year
and because of the amount of discovery
that was required for these what usually
happened is with the parallel tracks
everyone would agree to the same
Discovery schedule for the panel and for
the trial so you would go through the
same Discovery process a year and a half
to get to expert depositions and take
all of the expert depositions and by
that point the case is ready for trial
so there's no need to have a panel
um I'm not I don't think that answers
your question but I don't know the
statistics to properly answer that
follow-up
um yes I've raised the question what is
there any
the bill before us we're going to just
pull the plug on this whole process
immediately which obviously you're in
favor of in principle but there's any
downside to the three panels that are
already underway just immediately
terminating their work with uh
with like no is there any downside to
that or you think that's probably a
desirable outcome I don't
know that there are any panels currently
underway if there are three panels that
have been in paneled
um I I don't believe that they have
heard anything and I suspect that they
are likely to go the same way as panels
that I've been appointed to once
everyone reviews everything the panel
will be waived and the hearing won't be
held okay thank you thank you for
clearing other questions for this one is
representative
have you find found that there's even
Specialists available to be on these
committees I would just question that
there wouldn't be you'd be able to find
a doctor without a conflict of interest
for example my husband is an
Interventional cardiologist and I know
that there's
less than 30 of them licensed in New
Hampshire and
he knows pretty much all of them so are
these
people have you been able to actually
find people on a panel that don't have a
conflict of interest
um we have made motions to strike panel
members for conflicts of interest in the
past in the very early years I don't
work for the court system so I can't say
that I believe that Richard had
testified that that is one of the
biggest hindrances and that's why Angela
Pearl has taken has to do Google
searches or search on the internet to
try to find other Physicians but I am
not the appropriate person to answer
that right but you've had a strike so it
has been an issue in our mind at least I
and I think it's very difficult and
that's laid out in our article I believe
that's been the experience in Maine as
well that's one of the difficulties they
have and why it takes a year and a half
to get to panel hearings thank you other
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you chip dust next I'm going to call on
uh Gary woods from the New Hampshire
and actually just for reference I do
have a copy of the amendment that we've
been referencing
um okay you have to yeah you need to I
do have a copy for the record uh a copy
of the amendment that we've been
discussing that I'll that I'll share
okay
this is okay go ahead thank you Mr chair
and committee uh my name for the record
is Gary Woods um
um I'm representing the medical society
I'm a retired orthopedic surgeon
um specialized in hand surgery and
jokingly uh said I specialize just in I
did the left hand
but um
I you said the right hand is much too
complicated at which point I was
accosted by left-handers and said what I
mean demeaning my left hand
um
I um as as noted previously I was on the
panel
um uh to uh in 2005 that there was a
formulation for the panel system
um and indeed as anything touched by
human hands is imperfect and I think
what we've heard today is all those
imperfections
however contrary to what my daughter
said when we had a flat tire she said
why don't we just get a new car
um I think what we're seeing here is the
kinds of things that we would like to
see
in a good panel
and with that in mind I am advocating
against the current bill as promulgated
and amended by the Senate but by the
I have some sort of semi-random notes
and I'll try and Skip through them why
delay versus just repeal
when looking at something that we were
trying to get a study committee that we
were advised that in fact uh that was
any study committee was going to be
looked on with a strong disfavor
in the legislature this year because of
uh activates and having been a
legislator myself for two terms I can
will agree that you can be overburdened
rather rapidly
but nevertheless having something on the
books that in fact uh when you're going
out and trying to get players to
participate it's one thing just to do it
on your own but if you can point to the
legislation that says we want to look at
it because that's what that message
would be
we want to look at it
we think panel systems may have some
Merit a current system has not worked in
many dimensions as we've heard
of cost administrative and so forth
but those are all points that would be
taken into consideration to make it
better
another point I'd like to just emphasize
is that medicines changed since 2005 in
case you hadn't noticed uh I think we
all have
one of the things is I would just ask
how many private practice doctors do you
know just offhand
uh everybody has to pause everybody's a
corporate
position they are owned by a corporation
there are a lot of constraints playing
placed on Physicians both economic as
well as ethical
and those come into play and I won't
delve into all of them but that comes
into play and May in fact be a measure
of why we see so many settlements
because
it used to be the the private physician
feeling that he had you know something
to defend
would in fact work hard to to fend to
defend himself but now
and again I um I've
the numbers say there's a lot of
settlement
my contention may be that one factor not
the factor but one factor is that
corporations say it's easier to settle
and it's less costly
so let's settle and I don't have all the
numbers
and I'll hearken back to my previous
profession as a physicist that I love
numbers but you've got to remember it's
not the numbers it's how you interpret
the numbers
that's important
and I think as we go through this
process
and any committee that would look at it
would have to look at the numbers and
what they mean
okay and when I say that I mean what
what does though what do those numbers
mean
and at Harkins a Segway to another point
and what does it mean
I've yet to heard hear the word patient
mission
this is basically we're talking about an
act against a patient
and a patient is trying to get
some sort of
this panel system and all of our
malpractice system is a mechanism to try
and write that wrong
in some way
can't go back in time
but there's a recognition
and I think we have to keep that in mind
that
these efforts that we're going through
now represent
patient advocacy
and again patient
front and center what can we are we
doing the right thing
for the patient yeah we want to make it
work for everybody
for the judicial
or the attorneys
we want to we want to make it so it
works for everyone
but we can't forget that the real reason
is is
and all of medicine is predicated just
on that
without
I say
the constraints of cost other than the
corporations telling us we have to lower
costs
and I'll give you an example
that we look we look at patients and not
costs
if I if I were to ask you
uh or I could tell you I could save you
immediately and long term well why not
I say well
I'm trying to advocate for no smoking
okay one of the we shouldn't be
advocating for no smoking
because you die earlier
okay you save money because you don't
you don't have a stroke you don't have
an MI you don't have all these medical
problems you don't go into a nursing
home you don't have total joints
so if you want to save Health Care
dollars
advocate for smoking
now that's that's an absurd sort of
comparison
but our medicines is based on what we do
because it does come into play I'm not
saying we shouldn't consider it
my next point is that review is good
even
when I was on the panel and as president
of the medical society I'm sorry looking
I'll try and be brief
um
um the the whole idea of
that it's not perfect and we we knew
that
but the important thing is is to make it
better because like we make our highways
better and safer
we should do the same here
um just a quick comment about
settlements
uh it touches briefly and any group that
would study this issue could study this
as well or at least raise the issue
because we want to be able to not miss
take care of patients but also make sure
we look at who in fact in fact there was
some harm done
is it properly being addressed
and sometimes settlements
any comments about whose right or wrong
gets buried
and that might not be in the patient's
without going into detail I can tell you
that does occur
so
um
having things out a little bit more in
the open can be very much to everybody's
been the Public's benefit
um
I'll um I'll stop there questions
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you I'm sorry do you
want to say something you know yes yes
please
um so thank you Mr Jim you can tell us
who you are yes of course uh my name is
Mike padmore I'm the director of
advocacy with the New Hampshire Medical
Society uh and thank you Mr chairman or
give me the time to speak and members of
the committee um what I'd love to do is
um I do have a written statement I'd
like to touch on some of those different
pieces I did share a couple copies of
written testimony from Dr OG young and
Dr Daniel Al bushes I would like to read
a short excerpt we've you know given the
time we've we've we've got it and you
know we'll all read it so in fact I have
already read it that's for both of them
that's fair and I really would encourage
folks to especially read Dr Daniel Al
Bush's uh testimony where
um she uh in 2013 did utilize this panel
process
um and I think that gives you uh some
sense into the value of this process
we're not saying that it's perfect I'm
not I'm not going to sit here and say
that this is a system that is operating
the way that it should that it's
operating efficiently and so when the
when the judicial branch came to us and
it was in October of 2022.
um we we discussed you know a potential
repeal um you know we felt that having
an opportunity to study it would be
worthwhile and helpful to this process
that was the bill that you know we
testified on in January and it's
obviously turned into this um and so
what what our hope is and the amendment
that I've shared with you all
um not to rehash too much but it is a
three-year pause it is a repeal it gives
us the opportunity to continue to work
on this existing statute representative
Perez I know that you had given a
question to Paula minahan around you
know why not just repeal it and I think
I do share the sentiment that Paula had
around you know keeping that Statute in
place it doesn't do any harm certainly
if we are pausing this system and then
repealing it after three years that's on
us that's on me I recognized that in
2005 the New Hampshire Medical Society
where the proponents of this of this law
and I recognize I wasn't part of the
organization back then I was I think I
was going into high school
um so I recognized that there are some
things that we have to own as part of
our organization bringing this forward
um and I'd like to be part of doing that
and so one of the things that I want to
focus on if you are to pass this bill as
amended the amendment that I've shared
with you all
we intend to organize the different
stakeholders some of them that are in
this room of course the defense folks
the plaintiff folks
um the folks working in malpractice
carriers the hospitals the Physicians
how can we identify a way to make this
process work more efficiently I want to
address something that representative
churrer also brought up around you know
potentially a you know an opt-in process
and an attorney Haynes did address that
and saying well that was something that
essentially the medical society changed
when we when we adopted this new law I'm
here to tell you right now that we
wouldn't necessarily be opposed if we
went back to that because I think what
the issue here is is that there are
opportunities or there there um there
are occasions where you may have a
physician like dockered al-bushies where
she feels that she did not deviate from
the standard of care and feels that she
would like to go to this panel and feels
that that panel will give her an
opportunity to explain what happened in
that case and so what I'm saying is is
that I would like to find a way to make
this process work for all parties and
right now we understand that it isn't
working for the judicial branch
hear that you know to representative
Smith's question around it yelling that
quite honestly I don't we wouldn't
support it just from the standpoint of
we hear what the judicial branch is
saying we we don't we don't think that
makes sense we don't want to Advocate to
keep a process in place that isn't
working so that was our attempt through
this compromise originally in the
introduce Bill and then in this this
proposed amendment that I've sent around
to all of you right now to give us an
opportunity
um to to try to to address this and fix
this so with that I'm happy to answer
any questions questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much
I know that you've been here a while so
I'll try and be brief my name is Brad
Holt I'm a partner at Solway and Hollis
I've been defending medical malpractice
cases since 1995.
almost without exception
I'm not here on behalf of any client I
just think that this process uh has some
value and so I'm giving you a defense
lawyer's perspective on that as you do
your legislative work and decide what to
do I I oppose the ending of the panel
process but I do recognize there are
some areas that could be improved and
there have been some good ideas uh today
that I hope you'll consider as this goes
forward it was uh I think an appropriate
effort to try and
short-circuit the expensive and
stressful process Dr Woods referred to
the to the patient or the plaintiff
likewise for the physician it's a it's a
tough process it's expensive if there
were a way to limit that that would be
helpful both for reducing costs but also
for the benefit of both parties and so
this was a good effort to do it everyone
says it's not working it's not working
as designed but I guess we'd have to
Define not working because there are
some aspects again that render this to
be a good tool when it's used
every tool is not useful for every
project and so often cases resolve
without
panels even without mediation by direct
negotiation between the parties and
sometimes things have to go all the way
to a jury to get resolved so this is
just one of the ways that we can
resolve cases and I think it should go
forward if you'll consider some uh
modifications to how it works it is true
that they're pretty rare and I'll try
and identify a couple of reasons but my
firm Solway and Hollis had one within
the last year I haven't had any in
several years but I did spend a few
years in Chicago and a year on Military
overseas but before that had some and
again even even since its Inception
often it would get waived and there are
reasons for that
two panel cases I had that had a 3-0
unanimous finding for the defendant
resulted in a resolution of that case
without a settlement without a trial
that was certainly
terrific from my client's perspective
and uh I had one in Maine I don't
practice in Maine but I was there for a
particular case and it was a 3-0
unanimous finding in that case that
ended it all the litigation costs all
the frustration
for the parties
but in cases that I've had for the panel
response was a split verdict or
unanimous for the plaintiff that that
resulted in in settlement pretty quickly
because uh it was
persuasive on my client let me um let me
address a couple of the points when I
say it's
have defined not working
it was supposed to resolve cases early
and I think everyone agrees
um that part isn't working rarely maybe
never has a case met the deadlines for
having a panel hearing and there are
reasons for that as you heard some of my
my colleagues on the plain side of
things
say medical malpractice cases are
challenging uh the the good
successful established plaintiffs
lawyers
um and and hard work and defense lawyers
know that they owe it to their clients
to work up a case sufficiently to be
able to represent it well and and of
course that's expensive but also it
means you wouldn't want to go into a
panel hearing without having certain
amount of of uh discovery which is where
we gather information that the other
side or we want to put into a future
trial so it's true they don't go early
so what that that in itself
doesn't add a cost
if if you can establish that
panel happening later in this whole
litigation process adds a cost that
might be different but I don't think it
does so just being outside the normal
time parameters isn't a concern and it's
often waived so what if it's waived
that's no cost either because we didn't
have to use a courtroom or Court staff
or electricity or if it isn't the
problem that the that the judicial
branch has to they don't know it's going
to be waived your honor of chairman I'll
address that at the end I think that's
true if if so that the problem is when a
panel is requested because it isn't
waived by both parties it's been very
difficult to schedule for reasons stated
you've got multiple people that have to
get their calendars together there are
challenges with conflicts of interest
and and finding members to create a
panel so that Court strain is a problem
that's a problem the whole panel process
when not used isn't necessarily a
problem but if it's used and it puts an
undue restraint
constraint on the the Personnel of the
Court that's a problem I would say that
sometimes that difficulty in scheduling
and and paneling three qualified people
often ends up being the reason that
there's a waiver we see that it's just
not happening and so we agree to move on
from the defense side of things so that
piece of the problem could be addressed
with some modifications without chucking
the whole panel process because as I say
sometimes it's valuable
um it's valuable when the 3-0 a
unanimous finding for a defendant
leads a plaintiff to drop the case all
those litigation costs that would go
after that that involve preparing for
trial are gone all the court resources
and again all the stress on on the
parties and when a plaintiff wins or
there's a split verdict and particularly
where the physician panelist
doesn't support a doctor that's quite
compelling to my clients and it really
invites them to think more strongly
about settlement so if there are cases
where the doctor on the panel is is the
one that won't go with the plaintiff's
case I haven't had that and I've had it
where the doctor agreed with the
plaintiff and then that was compelling
and so it can be useful to bring your
your client to to a proper settlement
the idea that there are two tracks I
would also oppose that as you heard from
uh I think Kevin Dugan indicated that
the first thing is the trial date and
then you move back with all the other
pieces of it
discover and likewise you heard I think
from Ms Haynes that uh
all this discovery has to happen before
a panel is going to be worthwhile before
people really know what they're talking
about so there's really One schedule
one track and a panel when impaneled
is a step along the way and if it's
waived then the the process continues
but it's not like trial panel
preparation is entirely separate from
trial preparation you're doing paper
Discovery your disclosing experts your
deposing parties deposing Witnesses
deposing experts to prepare for trial
and typically a panel will happen after
enough important information but not to
the nth degree that a trial is going to
required has been completed so I think
it's one pan one track the panel process
fits at an apt spot where experience
Council try and fit it when they've got
enough information but they can avoid
that last that last mile to to a verdict
is what's incredibly expensive and and
challenging
so uh a note that a panel is typically a
day sometimes even half a day most Med
mail cases are at least a week typically
into another week or even three weeks
and so if a panel is going to be
potentially efficacious the possibility
of savings is huge because every day in
court and preparation for it is is
extraordinarily expensive likewise not
every witness including every expensive
expert that is going to come to trial is
brought to a panel if they've been
deposed their transcripts are are
admissible because the panel process is
not really a full mini trial The Rules
of Evidence are more lenient and so
there are some streamlined ways to put
in what would be evidence at trial
without bringing all the witnesses for
it so I'll conclude by saying
there are sometimes it's valuable
sometimes it's waived because it isn't
necessary the parties can directly
negotiate and experience council do that
pretty often sometimes it's through
mediation mediation is different than a
panel
I ordered the question about
um
a a plaintiff I think needs their day in
court they need to know they've been
heard and that mediation process
typically doesn't provide that it's
often lawyers and mediators getting it
done especially in this era of zoom and
I think there is some value of going to
a panel and both parties sitting across
the room hearing from the other side
seeing their their resolve seeing the
points they make that that can be an
important part of then getting someone
ready to reach a settlement so sometimes
the data is hard to read I guess as Dr
Wood said there was some interesting
data from Ms Haynes and Miss Kirkland
but it would be hard to decipher what
led to settlement and the timing of it
so just looking at those raw numbers
don't necessarily tell the story the
timing of of settlement often is
sometimes cases go to mediation and
don't settle until after that people
have time to process it and then come
back together and resolve it so
recommendations would be that you'd have
a period of time to make some
modifications there was a point about
compensating panelists only the Justice
the retired Justice that chairs the
panel gets paid and I I don't remember
the amount I'm sure it's
not a lot but the the Physicians that
take a day off of work you know a day
off of surgery uh that's a that's a big
ask so there may be a way to to
compensate panelists and that might make
the pool of panelists more readily
available so that that impediment to
panels of
just a challenge of getting them
together would be reduced uh likewise a
stronger encouragement for people to
participate I think it was
representative kutab's suggestion that
the hospitals have some incentive to say
please serve on one a year but that kind
of mechanism to ensure that it's part of
your your professional responsibility to
participate in panels would be helpful
third just modifying the timing
expectation I think this is a big one
as soon as a case is filed and there's
an effort to identify who the panel
chair would be the judge or the retired
the retired judge chairman chairperson
the whole process doesn't get started
and that could be you could hold off on
that until a time something like the
opt-in idea before you really impaneled
the group before you started preparing
materials for it because we know it's
not going to happen for a while so truly
from the day it starts for that that
first six months or 11 months or often
longer there's nothing for the panel to
do that's not where the timing happens
it's only when they're coming in for a
landing but modify that expectation
forget the sixth month and 11 month uh
deadlines that are in the statute but
which can be waived for good cause and
always are and then finally
um
uh just to ensure that there's a
commitment you could modify the way the
impalement process occurs so that there
isn't any kind of false start cost
whereby panels were waived at the 11th
hour I suppose if they're waived at the
11th hour because a case settled
with an impending panel
maybe the panel had some effect on that
without actually going forward so that's
why I say it's difficult to determine
what causes and effects are but
experience Counsel on both sides of the
aisle are are usually able to suss out
whether it's valuable to go to a panel
or not
and so this is a tool that's worth
keeping on the tool bench it doesn't get
used all the time but sometimes it's
effective
questions for this Witness
so Michelle I guess I one of the things
that that I'm not sure that I heard you
say or really any of the other Witnesses
who sort of oppose this and this is a
thing that's a great concern to me you
say and I think you're probably right
that there are some occasions
when the panel is useful
but it sounds like most of the time and
from the numbers that's certainly
you know seems to bear this out that
most of the time the lawyers on both
sides agreed to waive it and so they
find that it's not useful and so I guess
the thing I really have a my concern is
we we the panel system creates an
exception to the law that usually
applies in tort cases that that you know
the party plaintiff brings a lawsuit and
it goes they do their Discovery they try
to settle it goes to trial but here we
have we've carved out this
sort of separate practice for for
medical malpractice cases and initially
it was the argument was well there are
all these reasons we have to do it
insurance rates are up in the air
there's frivolous cases being brought we
need to do it for all these reasons
turns out that those reasons don't
really seem to be true
and so my question is why do we have to
have this special procedure that might
be helpful in a few cases but in most
most of the time is wave why why do we
why is it worth it even if it is even if
it is useful in a few cases well your
numbers might go up for for
um proceeding with the panel if it
weren't so hard to get one and that is
by no means a criticism of the Court
staff that have to find panel members
and that's particularly the medical
member if if it were easier it and I
think it we heard that this the
description of of a clerk having to
spend time looking up doctors and cold
calling people if it were easier to
establish a panel you wouldn't need all
that lead time if you knew you were
going to be able to get a panel a fair
panel that met the requirements and that
would be less of a reason to waive it
their defense lawyers do waive it when
it's just not coming together and we
need to move on with the case I would
say um
we we have mediation which is mandatory
when rule 170 came out and then rule 30
whatever so it's a mandatory and and you
heard uh testimony that it's mandatory
actually that sometimes gets waived as
well when experienced councils say your
honor we just see this case differently
we have worked it up to a fairly well we
know what we're doing and we think we
need to go we have had instances where
the judge said I won't waste your time
or your expenditure on paying a mediator
but and the and the role of mediation as
a nearly mandatory requirement is and I
agree with attorney Dugan on this point
probably part of the another reason why
panel use has been diminished so again
it's been diminished because it's been
cumbersome there are some ways to make
it more effective to and panel effective
and efficient for court staff and
participants between
um only only working to a panel them at
after a certain commitment to go
um compensating panelists
and encouraging participation
though it would be another tool
sometimes we mediate sometimes we don't
you know when rule 170 came out there
were several other Alternatives and
almost I don't know anyone who's ever
used neutral evaluation it withered on
the vine and it isn't used mediation
became the go-to way to resolve cases if
they weren't resolved after a panel all
right thank you are the questions for
this witness thank you very much thank
you
I don't have any other pink cards is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on sb65
all right then I'm going to close the
hearing on sb65 and we're going to take
a 30 minute break when we will take up
uh session and I'm uh I'm gonna uh open
the hearing on uh Senate bill 264.
and uh
call the uh primary sponsor uh Senator
Perkins sorry
no problem chairman it's um it's a
Polish name if that helps so it rhymes
um nice to be here with you guys today
and my my pink card is making its way
around to you so I am Senator Perkins
cooka as the chairman stated um for the
record from Senate District 21
representing Portsmouth Durham New
Market and several other Seacoast
communities
so um
Senate Bill 264
addresses essentially the assisted
reproduction statute and the motivation
of it is really to update it
um I unfortunately had two very
experienced practitioners here with me
to answer the really technical questions
for you but
um they both had to leave and so the
intent really is to make sure that we
are using our court system officially
that we've sort of reflected in our
assisted reproduction statute
um realities that families experience
and so
um you know as a same-sex couple my wife
and I have had two kids we've had to go
through confirmatory adoption hearings
in the court system and there was
um you know that's still the advice for
same-sex couples even mothers like me
who carried and gave birth to their two
girls so I think what we want to make
sure is just that
um as Justice Lynn has probably
experienced making sure we're respecting
the efficiency of our dockets if we
could just provide some of these
language updates in the bill it not only
um provides Assurance to a wider
audience but also makes our statute more
inclusive to reflect
um same-sex couples and just sort of the
the many ways that families come to be
in New Hampshire so I think that we all
share a goal of making sure that our
families are healthy and thriving and
our kids are well taken care of and so
creating certainty around assisted
reproduction parental rights donor
rights surrogate rights gestational
carrier agreements it's that is really
the intent of this bill
um
and so with that I think I will probably
wrap up to take any questions with one
final note that um you'll you'll see in
the docket that at
um at the end of the day this was a
bipartisan vote coming out of the Senate
and so we were able to work together on
a bipartisan basis to resolve a couple
language concerns
um about pronouns but I did not receive
any concerns about the technical aspects
of the bill so happy to answer any
questions right questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you well that was easy
thank you committee
all right um
and I take it no one I see anyone else
here to testify on 264 264.
representative Eaton as you would you
like to say something and we're happy
happy to hear from you if you'd like to
say something
[Laughter]
all right thank you very much so not
saying I'm going to close the hearing on